très heureuse de vous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle émission bonjour chez
vous c'est votre rendez vous quotidien
avec l'actualité qui vous concernent des
débats des reportages
[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
ici dans la salle des conférences du
sénat
vous allez suivre l'audition du ministre
de l'intérieur christophe castaner sur
la crise du coronavirus il sera
notamment question du respect du
confinement par les français pendant
cette crise sanitaire
je vous laisse écouter cette audition
pour que pendant cette période le
confinement soit efficace et je crois
que c'est très important je dois
souligner qu'ils sont particulièrement
exposées au risque de contamination dans
leur travail
et comme vous pouvez le pressentir nous
avons des questions à vous poser à cet
égard sur la disponibilité des masques
pour nos forces de sécurité nous
veillons particulièrement dans cette
mission de suivi à laquelle s'associent
tous les membres de la commission des
lois par visioconférence à ce que
pendant la période de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
l'état de droit ne soit pas mise en
suspension mais simplement aménagé avec
des règles spécifiques mais ces règles
peuvent être strictement respectés sans
sortir du cadre légal même exceptionnel
que nous mettons en oeuvre
c'est une mission de suivi ce n'est pas
une commission d' enquête s'inscrit dans
un cadre coopératif avec le gouvernement
nous avons voté cette loi d'urgence
sanitaire et nous suivons son
application comme le faisons en temps
ordinaire pour d'autres loin outre la
police la protection des policiers et
des gendarmes qui nous préoccupe
nous aurons beaucoup de questions à vous
poser sur la cohérence des pratiques en
matière de verbalisation et de contrôle
nous allons constater parfois un certain
flou une certaine
diversité dans l'action des forces de
sécurité je suis sûr que vous en êtes
conscients et que vous veillerez à ce
que des instructions fermes continue
d'être données pour qu'on ne s'écarte
pas d'une stricte interprétation de la
règle nous poseront également quelques
questions sur l'impact du confinement
sur l'ensemble du dispositif de sécurité
publique pendant le coït 19 la menace
terroriste subsistent de la même façon
si les actes de délinquance sur la voie
publique sont évidemment moins nombreux
il y à d'autres risques qui surviennent
qu'on essaye de mesurer qu'il faut
traiter et je sais que vous en avez pris
tout à fait conscience c'est par exemple
les violences intrafamiliales violence
conjugale ou violence à l'égard des
enfants
et enfin nous soulignerons la nécessité
d'une bonne coordination pour l'exercice
de leur pouvoir de police respectifs
entre les préfets et les maires puisque
nous avons vu apparaître des divergences
à cet égard il ya des situations locales
spécifiques qu'il faut bien sûr traiter
le mieux c'est tout de même qu'on arrive
à les traiter dans le bon ordre puisque
je parle des mères dont le rôle est très
important pendant cette période et dont
le rôle va être plus important encore au
moment de la réouverture des écoles
communales c'est à eux de veiller à ce
que matériellement l'accueil se passe
dans des conditions de sécurité
sanitaire pour les enfants les parents
et les enseignants
je voudrais souligner que nous avons
également une préoccupation très vive
celle de l'élection des 30000 mères et
de leurs adjoints dans les communes pour
lesquelles le premier tour des élections
municipales a été conclusif il faut à
cet égard sans doute que nous
réfléchissions aux moyens d'aller vite
pour ne pas rester dans un entre deux
qui soulève des difficultés dans un
certain nombre de communes même si ça
nous permet aussi de bénéficier de
l'expérience de mer chevronnés qui vont
quitter leurs fonctions dans les
prochaines semaines voilà un ensemble
de questionnements de points de
vigilance que nous mettrons en avant
pendant cette position je vous propose
de vous donner d'abord la parole pour un
exposé introductif
ensuite nous vous poserons des questions
plus précises que ces grandes séries de
préoccupations que je vient d'exprimer
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
merci de votre invitation dans le cadre
de cette mission d'évaluation de
contrôle mais surtout de co construction
parce que je vois aussi comme cela
l'ambition de notre travail au ministère
de l'intérieur avec les parlementaires
je me suis plié un exercice dans un
style différent mais de présentation
aussi de notre activité la semaine
dernière à l'international et j'ai vu
combien un certain nombre de questions
ont pu nous alerter sur de nombreux
points je ne doute pas qu'il en soit de
même cette après midi l'état d'urgence
sanitaire et la crise que nous
traversons impose chacun le sait un
certain nombre de mesures d'exception et
vous le savez ici mieux que d'autres
puisque vous avez accompagné la loi
d'urgence sanitaire et si elle imposée
elle permet d exception elle oblige
l'exécutif à des décisions rapides
urgente
alain postes chacun de ces aux français
des sacrifices alain pose à nos
soignants un travail exceptionnel et
vous l'avez dit aussi aux forces de
sécurité civile et de sécurité
intérieure un travail remarquable mais
qui est effectivement pas simple pas
simple à mettre en oeuvre et certaine de
votre question montre les limites de cet
exercice et je tenterai de répondre
aussi face à cette difficulté à la façon
dont je crois qu'ils réalisent au mieux
et très bien leur mission
même si cela ne nous absous pas de
critiques possibles de contestation
voire de plantes qui peuvent exister
mais j'y reviendrai mais vous l'avez dit
en parallèle je ne suis pas surprise
devant la commission des lois du sénat
que vous posiez cela comme un préalable
il n'est pas question pour autant de
renoncer au fondement de notre
république à ses valeurs
dossier à son organisation et à cet
équilibre de notre démocratie
parlementaire qui veut que nous devons
aussi rendre des comptes et c'est aussi
dans cet esprit là au delà la
coopération que je suis devant vous et
je crois qu'il est important aussi que
vous montriez que le travail
parlementaire se poursuit dans toute sa
dimension
c'est un message aussi que vous adresser
aux français était nécessaire que nous
le zip lions comme je le dis pour
l'assemblée nationale mais je le fais
évidemment de de bonne grâce
car c'est dans ce travail là que nous
devons marquer notre capacité à nous
unir même si on peut avoir des
désaccords et des critiques parfaitement
légitime mais c'est cette façon là aussi
que nous devons agir devant la crise
sanitaire puis surtout devant les
français qui nous écoutent et les
journalistes qui relaieront je pense nos
échanges avant de répondre à vos
questions auxquelles vous m'avez invité
par quelques unes et je voulais traiter
dans ce propos liminaires et plus pour
d'autres une rebondir on voulait évoquer
les principales tâches qui sont celles
du ministère de l'intérieur depuis le
début de l'épidémie vous dire que nous
n'avons évidemment pas attendu pour agir
que des décisions étaient prises très
vite à l'aune de l' expertise toujours
des médecins et des scientifiques et ses
décisions poursuivi toujours
inlassablement le même objectif
préserver la santé des français assurer
la capacité de notre système de soins à
tenir le coup évidemment elles sont
critiquables comme toute décision
politique mais elles n'ont jamais varié
de ce but là et je tiens à le réaffirmer
et je voudrais réaffirmer au site où tu
étais profiter de cette audition pour le
redire mais je n'ai pas besoin de vous
convaincre sur le fait que nous ne
sommes pas au bout du combat que nous
devons mener contre le virus nous sommes
même loin du bout du combat que nous
devons mener mais nous pouvons d'ores et
déjà comme le président de la république
l'a fait lundi soir voir les premiers
effets de notre engagement collectif
contre le virus de cet engagement de
celui des personnels soignants qui joue
ce rôle décisif et qui ont fait ce
travail que chacun salue non pas chaque
soir même s'il ya un rendez vous devenu
symbolique mais à chaque instant parce
qu'ils sont en première ligne contre le
virus et il est bon aussi qu'on puisse
évoquer leur travail mais derrière les
soignants il ya de nombreux français aux
divers métiers qui s'engagent sans
compter et par mieux je veux
effectivement souligné l'implication
exceptionnelle du ministère de
l'intérieur au sens le plus large de ce
qu'il représente le ministère de la
citoyenneté je pense aux préfets et aux
sous-préfets aux acteurs du territoire
et et nous aurons l'occasion d'en parler
je pense à nos forces de sécurité
je pense aussi à notre sécurité civile
et aux pompiers que nous accompagnons
même s'il ne relève pas directement du
ministère de l'intérieur et vous dire
aussi combien est peut-être nous aurons
l'occasion d'y revenir j'ai vu la
capacité d'adaptation et en particulier
des pompiers qui ont su diversifier puis
qui est totalement leur champ
d'investigation pour répondre à toutes
les sollicitations
quand il était sollicité ma mission
aujourd'hui devant vous comme les
intérieurs c'est d'abord d'assurer le
respect des mesures vous l'avez dit
nécessaire au confinement pour faire
face à l'épidémie de covin dans le cadre
de l'urgence sanitaire et en premier
lieu le confinement vous l'avez dit pas
seulement hommage il reviendrait il ya
dans le confinement des mesures de
restriction de l'ouverture de certains
lieux accueillant le public aussi et
c'est une mission à laquelle toute notre
administration est mobilisé j'ai évoqué
le corps préfectoral et jour et
commencer par eux parce que le corps
préfectoral les personnels de préfecture
travaille vraiment d'arrache-pied pour
veiller à la bonne application des
décisions qui sont prises sur le terrain
et pour en assurer la bonne exécution
et ce sont eux et devant le sénat
évidemment je veux les évoqué en premier
sont eux qui travaillent à cette
coordination permanente et très
fructueuses avec les collectivités
locales qui sont des acteurs
déterminants de notre combat contre les
contre l'épidémie
je reviendrai sur la doctrine et les
quelques désaccords qui ont pu être
pointé je vais vous livrer immédiatement
un témoignage nous étions ce matin avec
le premier ministre en lien avec une
conférence avec l'ensemble des
associations d'élus si je ne devais
retenir qu'une seule conclusion c'est la
demande expresse faites par toutes les
associations de maintenir ce lien fort
qui existe dans la gestion de crise avec
les préfets si je devais retenir une
synthèse c'est plus de préfet encore et
je crois que au moment où on entendra
beaucoup de commentaires sur tel ou tel
arrêté
et quand je dis tel ou tel sont des
arrêtés qui se comptent sur les doigts
d'une main
tel ou tel arrêté de mer sur lequel j'ai
effectivement demandé au préfet de se
rapprocher des maires pour les ré
ramenée à une doctrine plus conforme
avec ce que nous appliquons niveau
national on en a beaucoup parlé mais sur
le quotidien ce que j'ai entendu ce
matin marc bien l'importance que les
services de l'état au plus près du
terrain on dans ce lien fort qu'ils
doivent faire vivre il ya eu aussi
monsieur le ministre
certes un arrêté du préfet qu'il a fallu
rapporté les maires ne sont pas les
seuls à être exposés à des irrégularités
dans leur décision
vous parlez à quelqu'un qui a été maire
pendant 17 ans monsieur le ministre est
donc évidemment je suis attaché à cela
mais je n'ai pas souvenir que nous ayons
des arrêtés qui est qu'ils aient fait
l'objet de recours et qui fasse débat au
conseil d'état alors que c'est le cas
sur des arrêtés de mer ça nous intéresse
à vous il ya eu je faisais allusion
simplement l'arrêté du préfet de
seine-et-marne qui notamment à mobiliser
des chasseurs qui sont allés jusqu'à
faire des procès verbaux d'infraction
mais c'est simplement pour dire que au
fond la tâche est difficile pour tout le
monde et pas simplement pour les mères
je vous avez raison mais on pourra en
parler en particulier pas de cet arrêté
qui n'a pas été rapportée parce qu'en
fait il avait une date limite de durée
mais effectivement j'ai souhaité qu'il
ne soit pas reconduit parce que c'était
à mon sens dans la mise en oeuvre une
rare d'interprétation mais globalement
d'ailleurs je peux rebondir sur ce jeu
mais je voudrais pas trop long dans mon
propos liminaire toute la difficulté
c'est que nous devons être pragmatiques
nous avançons en marchant comme dit
l'adage des protestants et savait que
quelquefois une règle posée mise en
oeuvre dans des délais extrêmement
courts peut prêter à des interprétations
qui ne sont pas les bonnes et je mets
cela évidemment sur la responsabilité du
ministère de l'intérieur de veiller à ce
que nous puissions fluidifiait mais
aussi de débrancher et je le fais assez
régulièrement voire même m'excuser je
souvenir de l'avoir fait devant le sénat
lors d'une crue âgées sur des actes qui
visent à vis des collectivités locales
n'était pas conforme à la volonté de
travailler ensemble cette volonté que
j'évoquais précédemment
je voudrais évoquer très rapidement mais
nous y reviendrons
cet engagement des pompiers cet
engagement d des policiers cet
engagement des gendarmes et qui comme
vous l'avez dit
ne se fait pas au détriment du reste de
leur engagement c'est vrai pour les
pompiers d'évidence mais c'est vrai
aussi pour nos policiers pour nos
gendarmes et de façon la plus extrême le
drame de romans sur isère il ya dix
jours la durement rappelé le confinement
ne fait pas débat disparaître les
risques et en particulier ne fait pas
disparaître le risque était au risque et
tous nos services de police de
gendarmerie de renseignement ont pris
les mesures pour assurer un niveau de
protection contre cette menace qui reste
inchangé et hélas permanente pour preuve
que soul empire de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire de nouvelles me casse ont été
prises des visites domiciliaires
continue à être organisé et les gets
départementaux par exemple continuent à
être animés parce que c'est
particulièrement de nécessaire de le
faire et je veux dire que nous y
veillons avec laurent de neige pour que
tout le ministère ne néglige pas ce
regard dans cette même direction celle
de la protection des français même si
évidemment nous devons tout prendre
prendre toute notre part dans le combat
contre le coc vie de 19 contre le virus
mais cela de ne pas nous faire échapper
de cette mission fondamentale de
sécurité de protection qui à partir au
ministère de l'intérieur
ce que je veux dire c'est que sur ces
sujets d'ailleurs n'ont pris que nous
aurons mis en place des doctrines
spécifique d'organisation notamment pour
tout ce qui est du haut du spectre de
nos services j'ai évoqué le risque
terroriste je pensais la dg a si je
pense et côté police judiciaire je
pensais à l'as date nous avons fait en
sorte qu'il y ait systématiquement une
équipe à une équipe b pour faire en
sorte qu'ils ne se croisent jamais pour
faire en sorte que nous puissions
répondre à toute sollicitation
il était parti de leur nécessaire de le
faire de la même façon l'organisation du
temps de travail dans la police en
particulier a été mis en place très vite
pour prendre en compte un combat une
mobilisation que nous savons longues et
donc il nous fallait effectivement
assumées une réorganisation du temps de
travail en particulier pour prendre en
compte cette dimension là et nous
l'avons fait assez tôt dès le 1er mars
j'ai demandé le renforcement de la
cellule ministérielle de veille compte
du contexte que nous connaissions puis
au lendemain d'une réunion du conseil de
défense et de sécurité nationale le 17
mars sa décision a été prise d'activer
la cellule un terminal de crise cic
j'aurais l'évoqué rapidement 7 6 et vous
en connaissez évidemment
le contours juridiques vous savez quelle
est la cic du premier ministre même si
c'est la cic beauvau elle est présidée
par le premier par ses services et que
le musée intérieure est en charge de son
animation de l'exécution des décisions
qui sont prises et qui sont prises par
le premier ministre dans le cadre de
l'animation gouvernementale qui est de
sa responsabilité et qui pour les mettre
en oeuvre suez évidemment les
orientations fixées par le président de
la république notamment lors des
conseils de défense nationale il y en a
eu deux au début de la crise voire des
réunions exceptionnelles qui étaient
mobilisés il y en a un par semaine qui
traite tous ces sujets là et qui permet
ensuite sous l'autorité du premier
ministre de prendre toutes les décisions
ministérielles et interministérielle qui
s'imposent les arbitrages rendus en cic
sont ensuite relayés aux préfets et
préfets que je réunis moi même tous les
soirs en visioconférence évidemment pour
expliquer les mesures décidées mais
aussi pour m'assurer de l'effectivité de
mise en oeuvre des décisions prises
outre que ces échanges sont nécessaires
pour faire redescendre les informations
et les instructions sont utiles aussi
pour faire remonter les romans pour
faire pour favoriser les remontées de
terrain et bénéficier directement à mon
avis à mon niveau pardon du niveau d'
analyse des prêts faits par rapport au
retour de terrain et aussi avec les élus
et des interrogations qu'ils ont deux
fois par semaine ce dispositif est mixte
c'est une réunion des préfets de région
des ars sous la double autorité du
ministre de la santé d'essayer d'arrêter
et de moi même
la cic au monde nous parle c'est 70
personnes ce sont deux ministères qui la
constituent évidemment hébergés à
beauvau mais qui porte l'ensemble de ce
travail interministériel et je veux
rajouter vraiment insisté sur le fait
que la suisse est un outil de
coopération interministérielle qui est
en lien permanent avec le centre de
crise sanitaire du ministère des
solidarités et de la santé sur le volet
réponse sanitaire vous le savez aussi
avec le centre de crise du ministère des
affaires étrangères pour ce qui concerne
la problématique de tous les français
qui étaient à l'étranger
qu'il s'agisse de français qui étaient
provisoirement à l'étranger ou qui
s'ajuste de français établis à
l'étranger qui veulent rentrer et jouets
souligné
l'énorme travail qui a été fait aussi
dans ce cadre là même si on en parle
moins
c'est assez significatif de rapatrier je
crois cent soixante mille personnes dans
les conditions que nous connaissons de
blocage mondiale telle que nous l'avons
connue enfin je parlais au début de mon
propos de mon attachement au contrôle
parlementaire
là si c'est aussi un outil de ce
contrôle parlementaire et nous avons mis
en son sein une plateforme qui met à
disposition des deux présidents de
l'assemblée nationale et du sénat qui
permet d'accéder à l'ensemble des
arrêtés préfectoraux qui sont pris sur
le fondement de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire avec une mise à jour
hebdomadaire et qui permet justement aux
présidents à leur service et au sénateur
ou député qui travaille avec eux de nous
interroger sur la base de ce que nous
produisons et je crois que c'est
important aussi
et puis la cic enfin à une mission
particulière qui est de faire le lien
avec les collectivités locales et je ne
revient que très rapidement sur le rôle
des maires mais aussi les présents de
département les présentes région qui
sont aussi très actif et très engagé sur
ces sujets que je voulais saluer et dont
je veux vous redire combien je demande
au préfet de les accompagner de prendre
en compte leur souhait de les
accompagner au maximum mais évidemment
de rester dans leur rôle est de pouvoir
s'il le considère nécessaire
demandez à tel ou tel exécutive de
revoir un arrêté ou d'essayer de mettre
en coordination tout cela je prendre un
seul exemple les arrêté de couvre-feu
tels qu'ils ont été proposés au départ
par certains maires j'ai demandé au
préfet d'accompagner les maires dans la
prise en compte de ces arrêtés y compris
avec un petit doute juridique d'ailleurs
sur la possibilité qu'ils avaient de les
prendre
quelquefois de les aider à réécrire les
arrêter conte
pouvait améliorer voire que le préfet
prenne un arrêté en lieu et place du
maire mais sur la base de sa volonté
pour faire en sorte qu'ils la sécurité
juridique dans certains cas je me suis
opposée où j'ai élargi
je me suis opposé quand j'ai eu des
demandes d'arrêter qui ne concernait que
des partis ou des quartiers de communes
j'ai demandé que si on arrêtait couvre
feu devait être pris il devait l'être
sur l'ensemble du territoire communal et
pas seulement sur tel ou tel quartier
pour éviter la stigmatisation de telle
ou tel quartier et à linverse quand un
nombre de mai important prenez arrêté de
couvre-feu j'ai suggéré ou les préfets
m'ont proposé que l'arrêté soit pris par
le préfet à l'échelle départementale
le premier ainsi prix fut pour les alpes
maritimes on avait un grand nombre de
mères qui avait pris l'initiative mais
pas tous mais du coup on avait une
incohérence dans la carte géographique
de l'arrêté de couvre-feu est donc dans
ce cas là on sait n'ont pas substituer
mais on a élargi et là par contre on a
assumé de prendre une décision que
certains maires ne voulait pas mais pour
avoir la cohérence entre trois communes
continue et une 4e au milieu qui ne
voulait pas le prendre ça nous semblait
extrêmement compliqué à gérer
et donc on a pris notre responsabilité
en élargissement cela ce que je veux
vraiment vous dire on a évoqué quelques
cas c'est que je crois que dans 99 et
demi pour cent des cas les échanges ont
été fructueux et se sont bien passées et
que quand il ya eu des incidents il
m'est arrivé de décrocher mon téléphone
soit pour regretter les incidents et et
soutenir mon administration médias que
je pouvais comprendre que dans la
pression interne utilisée et plus être
maladroit et alain verts se dire à mr
que je pensais qu'il avait un peu
dépassée de limites en tant que ancien
maire je voulais dire cela et à chaque
fois ça s'est bien passé je voudrais
vraiment insister sur cela parce que ce
que je souhaite et c'est peut-être
l'instruction permanente que je donne
aux préfets c'est que nous soyons à
l'écouté des élus pour faire remonter
les différentes problématiques
auxquelles ils sont confrontés et c'est
l'esprit de la réunion qui s'est
déroulée ce matin avec le premier
ministre c'était le cas par exemple sur
les marchés où j'ai invité aussi à une
approche sanitaires mais ensuite à une
approche pragmatique sur la base des
propositions des mers tel quel
remonté je ne vais pas revenir sur les
dispositions de la loi sur l'état
d'urgence sanitaire concernant les
élections municipales mais les questions
que vous avez posées sont des questions
qui ont été forcés ce matin à peu près
avec les mêmes mots par les associations
d'élus qui souhaitent l'installation la
plus rapide possible d un peu plus de
30000 conseils municipaux aujourd'hui
constitué et qui peuvent être installés
sauf contraintes sanitaires et c'est
vrai que j'ai dû rappeler ce matin le
cadre légal qu'il faisait qu après vous
avoir présenté à l'échéance du 23 mai
rapport sanitaire sur l'état du pays
nous serions amenés à prendre deux
décisions une sur le maintien en juin ou
pas des élections du second tour des
municipales et l'autre de l'installation
nous avons au fond sur ce sujet deux
cadres mais qui ne sont pas des dates
fixes le premier quart d'heure c'est au
plus tard le 23 mai et le sauvegarde
c'est au plus tard à la fin du mois de
juin pour les deux et donc c'est sur
cette base là qu'il faut qu'il ya un
échange qui se poursuivent
selah sue et du du premier ministre pour
que nous cherchions aller le plus vite
possible
si les conditions sanitaires de nous le
permettre dans les deux cas mais en
particulier pour l'installation des
conseils municipaux certains de nos
interlocuteurs ce matin aurait aimé que
dès le 12 mai nous puissions procéder à
la sortie du confinement à
l'installation des conseils municipaux
j'ai rappelé que notre objectif était de
s'appuyer sur le rapport que nous vous
présenterons pour prendre cette décision
mais c'est un sujet sur lequel je suis
intéressé d'avoir d'avoir vos retours
c'est nécessaire d'aller vite pour deux
raisons d'abord parce que la démocratie
locale le justifie
vu que les électeurs se sont prononcés
et puis ensuite parce que comme vous
l'avez rappelé monsieur le président il
est essentiel de donner aux exécutifs
locaux la légitimité électorale pour
agir vite et fort dans le combat que
nous devons mener ensemble et donc c'est
dans cet esprit là que nous devons
travailler il ya la question des epc qui
a été aussi posé et le président de la
commission des lois se souvient de ce
sujet des changes que vous avez eue avec
la présidente de la commission des lois
de l'assemblée nationale
on sait que nous avons un système qui
porte une forme de fragilité au moins
politiques pas juridique sur laquelle
effectivement nous avons être interrogé
je suis en
interrogé ce matin la discussion a eu
lieu là dessus pour conclure mon propos
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
si je viens de dracé dressé les grandes
lignes de notre organisation je n'oublie
pas évidemment vraiment notre action sur
le terrain et je n'oublie pas que la
consigne passée aux français et qui n'a
rien perdu de sa vigueur est claire elle
est sans ambiguïté autant que vous le
pouvez restez chez vous et que pour la
faire respecter nous avons mis en place
un certain nombre de mesures
il ya d'abord les attestations
dérogatoire de déplacements qui sont
obligatoires et dont nous avons expliqué
le fonctionnement et les exceptions aux
français c'est un travail de pédagogie
qui était particulièrement intense au
début du confinement mais que nous
continuons aujourd'hui et que nous
n'arrêtons pas ensuite cette règle nous
l'avons édictées pour tout le territoire
et nous avons donc fait en sorte qu'elle
soit respectée sur tout le territoire
sans exception ce sont en moyenne cent
mille policiers et gendarmes qui sont
déployés en permanence pour contrôler
nos concitoyens et le cas échéant
mais je dirais ça n'est que le cas
échéant et ça n'est en aucun cas un
objectif les verbaliser
j'ai toujours dit que je demandais de
forces de sécurité de protéger les
français en premier et la verbalisation
est à mon sens déjà un échec
ça n'est pas un objectif mais nous avons
mis en oeuvre ce dispositif près de 12 6
millions de contrôles ont été faits
pointage d'hier soir et 760 2106
verbalisations ont été dressées dans ce
cadre là notre dispositif s'appuie sur
une moyenne de 100 milles mais nous
avons su faire monter en puissance
encore ce dispositif sur certains
moments où on a craint des départs en
vacances
par exemple il ya une dizaine de jours
pour la zone parisienne où on a craint
le week-end de pâques comme étant le
moment où on allait se confiner ailleurs
non il n'y a pas de vacance dans le
combat contre le coc vide et donc nous
avons lui aussi sur ce sujet être
particulièrement ferme et sur ses
week-ends à parme ce sont 160 mille
hommes et femmes qui ont été mobilisés
et qui sont montés en puissance dans ce
cadre là et je ne veux pas oublier aussi
les polices municipales dans le texte de
loi que vous avez adopté
nous avons prévu la possibilité de doter
les polices municipales des capacités
adressé aussi procès verbal
nous avons ouvert ce droit très vite et
elles sont particulièrement mobilisés
aussi lmr là encore le son dans ce
travail de sensibilisation
je ne reviens pas sur le coup du non
respect du confinement mais je crois
qu'il est essentiel que nous allions sur
ce sujet que nous gardions sur ce sujet
une extrême vigilance parce que l'usure
et la difficulté du confinement
nous évoquions en aparté avant le début
de nos travaux
le fait qu'il était plus facile de vivre
le confinement quand on est dans une
résidence particulière avec un jardin
quelque part dans les
alpes-de-haute-provence que quand on est
dans un immeuble dans un quartier dans
une même dans un appartement à plusieurs
sans forcément avoir un abonnement
internet et les abonnements à toutes les
chaînes diverses et variées chacun avec
une tablette c'est aussi une réalité
sociale que le de confinement peut être
particulièrement difficile et donc les
conséquences de cela peut être un
relâchement le relâchement c'est la
reprise du risque face au co vide et
donc il nous faut sur ce sujet être
particulièrement attentifs tout comme et
j'en viens à une des questions que vous
avez posé
nous devons être attentifs à la
protection de nos forces de sécurité
intérieure et de nos forces de sécurité
civile et de nos pompiers
je les dis à l'assemblée nationale et je
le répète devant vous je ne suis pas
médecin je ne suis pas un expert
scientifique je m'en remets à leur
expertise et la doctrine gouvernementale
fixé en fonction de leurs analyses
dès la mi mars j'ai demandé à ce que des
kits de protection sera distribué dans
toutes les voitures de police et de
gendarmerie des kits de protection avec
notamment du gel et des masques de la
même façon dans tous les lieux d'accueil
du public pour l'épauler police pour les
policiers et pour les gendarmes et j'ai
précisé des masques qui devaient être
portées conformément à la doctrine
déterminé par les scientifiques c'est à
dire en cas d'intervention devant des
personnes présentant des symptômes ou
dans les cas de figure présentant un
risque important
il appartient aux policiers mais c'est
ce qu'ils font à chaque contrôle
d'apprécier la situation et de décider
cela des masques dont nous avons
d'ailleurs fait tout de suite des
commandes quand c'était nécessaire man
dont nous disposions aussi
au niveau de notre équipement de base
les chiffres sur ce sujet évolue en
permanence ils ont d'ailleurs changé
depuis mon audition la semaine dernière
à l'assemblée nationale et voici ce que
je peux avancer à la date du 15 avril 9
millions de masques sont à la
disposition du ministère de l'intérieur
et 4 millions qu'ont déjà été répartis
dans les unités d'ici la fin avril 9
millions de masques supplémentaires
seront livrés et au total ce sont 60
millions de masques que le ministère de
l'intérieur a commandé je n'évoque pas
mais peut-être qu'il préciserait plus
tard tout le matériel complémentaire
aussi lunettes visière et autre matériel
que nous avons acheté aussi pour
expérimenter la meilleure protection
possible pour nos forces de sécurité
intérieure mesdames et messieurs c'est
un terreau voici en quelques mots un
premier tour d'horizon de l'action du
ministère de l'intérieur pendant cette
crise une action résolue c'est une
action forte je crois qu'on en attend
pas moins du ministère de l'intérieur
quel que soit le ministre c'est une
action déterminée qui s'appuie sur ce
travail exceptionnel que vous avez
évoqué et que nous aurons l'occasion de
saluer en car je pense dans nos échanges
de tous les agents du ministère sur la
voie publique dans les casernes de
sapeurs pompiers en administration
centrale et aux préfectures je veux
aussi insister sur cette dimension là
aujourd'hui la santé des français
nécessite l'engagement tous je suis à la
tête d'un ministère qui sur ce sujet ne
lésine pas son engagement
voilà ce que je pouvais évoqué devant
vous en propos liminaire monsieur le
président bocoum ministre mes collègues
maintenant vous poser un certain nombre
de questions
pour ma part je voudrais revenir un
instant sur le dernier point je suis
comme vous je ne suis pas expert ni
médecin même si j'ai exercé des
fonctions dans le domaine de la santé
et vous dites devoir vous en remettre à
l' expertise mais l'expertisé le même
elle présente une caractéristique qui
rend parfois difficile de se fonder sur
elle c'est qu'elle est en partie fait de
vérité qui ont été expérimentalement
vérifier et en partie fait d'
incertitudes qui sont énoncés au fond
souvent l'expert définit le champ de
l'incertitude ce qui laisse entier le
problème de la décision de l'autorité
publique évidemment
et si nous ne sommes ni l'un ni l'autre
expert en santé
les gendarmes et policiers ne le sont
pas davantage
et comme vous avez une doctrine qui
consiste à leur dire qu'ils doivent
porter des masques et quand ils sont en
présence de personnes présentant des
symptômes
on est en droit de se demander comment
ils peuvent porter une telle
appréciation sur les usagers de la route
qu'ils vont contrôler à la sortie des
péages
je me demande au fond si cette doctrine
n'est pas une doctrine un peu de
circonstance est ce que la réalité ce
qui ce qu'on prendrait d'ailleurs n'est
pas que vous font vous n'aviez pas la
possibilité d'équiper massivement
policiers gendarmes et pompiers de
masques même si vous les avez commandé
vous en avez rappelé les chiffres et que
par conséquent il a bien fallu définir
une doctrine qui soit compatible avec la
réalité
ce qui m'importe e rey maintenant et me
rassurerait comme tous nos concitoyens
est d'abord les policiers et gendarmes
et les pompiers
c'est d'être sûr que dans un délai
rapproché leur protection sera
correctement assurée
alors d'abord on global le monde connaît
une tension forte sur les masques et le
monde de la santé connaît des
hésitations et des diagnostics divers
sur la nécessité de porter ou pas le
masque de façon permanente entre
l'organisation mondiale de la santé et
d'autres autorités certainement tout
autant légitimes et je n'aurai aucune à
niveau différent du nôtre
il y avait des débats sur cette question
là le monde entier a connu des
difficultés et on se souvient par
exemple que la france a mis à
disposition de la chine au début de la
crise des masques dont nous disposions
pour faire en sorte qu' il puisse aussi
faire face parce que même la chine à ce
moment là n'était pas en capacité
donc ces tensions sont nées tensions
mondiales que nous connaissons tous mais
je ne pense pas qu'elle est influencé la
doctrine qui étaient définis par des
professionnels de santé et qui nous ont
dit y compris j'ai organisé une
rencontre entre le professeur salomon
directeur général de la santé et les
organisations syndicales de policiers
qui ordi un certain nombre de
préconisations parmi ses préconisations
et je vais reprendre votre exemple très
concret celui du contrôle routier par un
policier ou un gendarme ce sont les
gestes barrière qui sont les premiers
niveaux de protection et qui permette
parfaitement au moment du contrôle
routier d'ouvrir assez peu la fenêtre et
de se protéger de ceux là ce même une
condition absolument indispensable mais
nous savons tous que même en étant très
sensibilisé il ya toujours une part de
risque
il y a aussi les agressions dont nos
forces peuvent faire l'objet le fait de
cracher au visage d'un policier ou d'un
gendarme est devenu une sorte de menace
suprême dont le masque ne protège pas et
nous savons aussi des problèmes de santé
ont évoqué la possibilité pour le virus
de se propager par les yeux ces raisons
aussi pour laquelle nous avons commandé
des visières nous avions des masques à
disposition et nous avons appliqué la
doctrine sanitaire compte tenu de la
nécessité de garantir aux professionnels
de santé d'avoir les masques et
notamment vous le savez nous allions 1
million 400 mille masques de type ffp2 à
notre disposition
cent mille pour la police un million
deux cent mille à peu près pour les
gendarmes et
150 ou 200 milles supplémentaires
étaient au sein de noces gamiq du
ministère de l'intérieur et j'ai fait le
choix de répondre à la doctrine
nationale et de mettre à disposition ses
masques de type ffp2 aux services de
santé et c'était la doctrine que nous
avons utilisé depuis le début c'est donc
un équipement de proximité qui est
laissée à l'appréciation mais vous
m'interrogez sur comment le policier
peut apprécier au fond comme il le fait
à chaque instant dans son métier il
apprécie une situation avec un certain
nombre de faits soudain 10 et à partir
de ces faisceaux d'indicés
il prend une décision c'est exactement
ce que j'ai demandé aux policiers aux
gendarmes pour appliquer cette doctrine
qui étaient déterminés par les
structures en responsabilité au
ministère de la santé de la solidarité
partage votre point de vue selon lequel
les masques ne dispenseront jamais de
respecter les gestes barrière mais à l
inverse les gestes barrière ne dispense
sans doute pas de d'être doté des
protections maximales et on voit de plus
en plus de gens porter de masque au fur
et à mesure qu'ils sont rendus
disponibles mais je crois qu'ils le font
non sans raison et même dans des
situations où on est moins exposé que
les policiers les gendarmes et les
pompiers donc c'est important que vous
arriviez à amener la protection
matérielle à un niveau qui donne au fond
la sécurité maximale à nos agents qui
sont terriblement exposées dans leur
mission pendant cette crise je crois que
vous partagez ce point de vue
certainement alors nous nous sommes
réparti la tâche monsieur le ministre
vous avez en face de vous une mission de
suivi
nous ne sommes pas tous autour de cette
table dans cette salle d'audition à
certain nombre de collègues sont reliés
à nous par visioconférence et nous avons
proposé à tous les membres de la
commission des lois compte tenu de
l'importance de cette condition de
pouvoir participer avec nous à aux
différents questionnements que nous
allons vous présenter eux
madame eustache brinio qui est à ma
droite monsieur sueur qui relié par
visioconférence vont vous poser les
premières questions qui concerne l'ordre
et la sécurité publics l'organisation
des services de sécurité intérieure y
compris gendarmerie police la sécurité
civile ce sera plus tard
et je vais tout de suite leur donner la
parole en commençant par madame eustache
brinio merci monsieur le président
monsieur ministre à quelques questions
effectivement je sais pas être trop long
parce que nous sommes nombreuses et
nombreux à vous poser des questions
moi je voulais revenir sur
l'organisation la continuité des
missions de sécurité puisque vous nous
avez précisé que cent mille policiers et
gendarmes étaient pratiquement affecté a
suivi à l'application stricte du
confinement ce qu'on comprend ce qui est
essentiel aujourd'hui pour préserver les
vies mais comme vous le savez vous le
savez mieux que moi pour certains entre
guillemets la vie continue et nous avons
quand même malheureusement même si on
entend tous les jours que la plupart des
français respecte le confinant ce qui
est vrai il ya une petite minorité qui
ne la suit pas et donc j'aurais voulu
savoir comment vous avez instauré
peut-être une priorisation des missions
de la police puisqu'il ya des choses
essentielles il ya des choses qu'ils
sont mois est-ce que sur un plan
organisationnel vous avez mis en place d
un certain d'adaptation dans le cas de
la des services de proximité
on sait très bien et et on le voit il ya
quand même même si on en parle peut
aujourd'hui parce qu'on parle
essentiellement de la lutte contre euro
vite agréé nier il ya eu qu'à
musellement assez dramatique le week-end
dernier il ya eu hier à la courneuve un
événement un peu compliqué donc on voit
bien moi j'ai ma collègue agnès canayer
qui m'a alerté sur les rodéos qui
reprenait et dans les quartiers
populaires verrou des hausses a fait
subir aux gens qui respectent
confinement un style bien peu difficile
donc voilà est-ce que malgré tout vous
avez pu organiser maintenir ses missions
de sécurité au quotidien pour que les
habitants puissent continuer à vivre
assez paisiblement ce confinement qui
est compliqué pour tout le monde et est
compliquée pour celles et ceux qui
vivent de effectivement dans des
quartiers populaires où on est
effectivement vous l'avez dit vous-même
parfois nombreux dans un appartement
mais on respecte bon on sait bien que
tout le monde ne le respecte pas je
voulais aussi une deuxième question je
posais mes trois questions et après je
ne prendrai pas la parole deuxième
question qui nous inquiète et qui nous
alertent ce sont les violences
intrafamiliales et en particulier
évidemment
et aussi les sujets la maltraitance est
ce que dans les commissariats ont été
maintenus les accueils tels qu'ils
étaient fait préalablement on sait que
ya pas a mis en place des accueils dans
les pharmacies mais on a très récemment
qu une lisibilité sur la réalité de de
cet accueil dans les pharmacies ce que
pour l'instant en tout cas quand on
échange avec les préfets personnes tous
aujourd'hui peut nous dire si les
pharmacies sont volontaires ou pas pour
accueillir en tout cas soutenir et
entendent réorienter ces femmes qui
subiraient des violences de même que
dans les centres commerciaux donc ça
c'est un sujet de préoccupation parce
que on nous dit qu'il ya moins d'appels
mais du coup qu'est ce que ça veut dire
on nous dit que on sollicite les voisins
pour aussi dénoncé ces des choses qu'il
pourra entendre mais on n'a aucune
visibilité et c'est un sujet
d'inquiétude pour beaucoup de maires bon
et puis troisième question vous avez
vous même lors de votre audition à
l'assemblée nationale
parler est dit que le confinement
pourrait avoir d'autres types de
conséquences et en particulier que vous
craignez le risque d'un renforcement du
communautarisme c'est un vrai sujet vous
savez qui c'est au sénat une admission
enquête sur ce sujet comment aujourd'hui
vous pouvez assurer et comment vous avez
pu mettre en place avec vos services
un suivi de ces phénomènes de de
repliement de repli sur soi parce que le
confinement ça doit pas impliquer le
repli communautaire et vous avez aussi
lors de votre audition à l'assemblée
parler des groupes d'ultras de droit et
d'ultra droite pendant une traque gauche
qui était très actif sur un réseau
sociaux et qui pouvait à la sortie du
confinement posé problème donc est ce
que vous le suit est ce que vous suivez
c'est phénoménal
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire plus
sur la manière dont on pourrait être
assurée sur ces trois pratiques que sont
le renforcement du communautarisme et
les milieux activistes j'ai envie de
dire merci merci beaucoup chers
collègues je donne la parole à monsieur
jean pierre sueur par visioconférence
en effet me tue paris oui alors chers
collègues vous êtes maintenant relié à
notre salle d'audition et vous pouvez
poser vos questions aux ministres ont
dit merci
alors ma première n'ont consisté à
revenir
réponse que vous appelez à philippa ya
quelques minutes
moi je reviens là dessus parce que les
policiers les gendarmes ils sont sur la
voie publique
qu'ils arrêtent de demander une voiture
de s'arrêter ne sont pas en mesure de
voir si la personne qui va répondre est
l'objet d'une fièvre ou de comportement
ou de ou de signes de symptômes donc la
vraie question gelard pose c'est de
savoir
il me paraît quand même nécessaire que
chaque gendarme
chaque policier a mené exécuter ces
tâches puisse être doté des protections
nécessaires donc à cet égard je voulais
vous demander si vous voulez bien une
réponse peut être plus clair
autre question sur le plan statistique
combien de personnes ont été placées en
garde à vue pour avoir violé à plus de
trois reprises les mesures de
confinement
combien ont été déférés et il n'y at il
pas une hétérogénéité dans le traitement
de ces questions troisième point il vous
avez annoncé que vous commandiez vous
avait annoncé le 12 avril que vous
commandiez 650 drones pour un montant
global de 3 8 millions d'euros
euh pourquoi à quoi ça va servir
vous avez dit que ces drones ne
servirait pas à effectuer et des avants
verbaliser des individus alors à quoi
sert pourquoi qu'en attendez vous
question suivante
pour ce qui est du 17 nous avons été
saisis de cas dans lesquels ce 17 était
engorgé et il n'y avait pas il ya une
sorte de saturation
est-ce que vous avez vu traiter cette
question
enfin dernier point où avant dernier
point je voulais vous demander votre par
rapport aux personnes sans papiers
nous avons compris que vous avez dit
qu'il était exclu de procéder à des
régularisations général mais il y aura
je suppose du statu quo pendant cette
période de confinement et d'autre part
comment ces personnes pour et pourront
accéder au sein même chose par rapport
aux centres de rétention
que comptez vous faire comptez-vous
réduire le nombre de personnes
accueillies
quid des personnes qui sont atteintes du
coc vide à l'intérieur des centres de
rétention dans quelle mesure ces
personnes sont ne sont pas susceptibles
d'être reconduite à l'extérieur
enfin je vous pose une question qui n'a
rien à voir sans doute mais depuis que
il est connu que nous allons vous
auditionnés je plonge je reçois comme
mes collègues quantité de réactions
dessus le ministre sur l'idée qu'après
le 11 mai et bien il y aurait un
confinement quelque sorte à jouer
absalon la hesse d'individus ça relève
pas du ministère de l'intérieur
mais ça relève du ministre que vous êtes
en tant que membre d'un gouvernement et
je me suis permis de dire cela parce
qu'il ya tellement de réaction à cet
égard que ça aurait été peut-être a
compris que nous ne vous posions pas la
question
même si elles relèvent d'autres de vos
collègues du gouvernement
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
oui monsieur le ministre sur sur les
masques puisque jean pierre sueur y est
revenu je vais quand même souligner que
vous avez pris une mesure importante que
vous avez annoncé
il ya peu de temps c'est de reconnaître
que covin 19 est une maladie
professionnelle
ce qui veut dire que vous percevez
parfaitement comme nous tous que nos
policiers et nos gendarmes sont exposés
à ce risque et il serait cohérent du
coup que au fond c'est sur demande une
réponse claire ce n'est pas de votre
réponse n'était pas claire mais elle ne
comportait pas d'engagement que la
doctrine actuelle pourraient évoluer au
fur et à mesure de la disponibilité de
suffisamment de matériel de protection
parce que je crois que le plus sûr
serait tout de même que nos policiers et
nos gendarmes soient dotées de masques
puisque le coc u19 est un risque
particulier qui justifie de le
reconnaître comme maladie
professionnelle ce que vous avez fait je
vais commencer monsieur présent par le
dernier point je n'ai pas demande je
n'ai pas décidé de la reconnaissance je
demandais que ceux qui sont en
responsabilité puisque reconnaître que
compte tenu des contraintes
particulières du métier de leurs
engagements cela puisse être fait je
n'ai pas de réponse au moment où je vous
parle à l'instruction est un peu longue
sur le sujet la doctrine que je mets en
oeuvre peut évoluer ce n'est pas le
ministre de l'intérieur qui décidera de
son évolution
parce qu'elle se fait sur des éléments
d'analysé médicale je l' ai dit tout à
l'heure nous avions des masques 1
million 400 mille masques disponibles
nous avons fait un choix celui de le
mobiliser se font au service du
personnel hospitalier qui est
particulièrement risque
il y à des gestes barrières des
distances nécessaires qui permettent de
faire en sorte que dans notre quotidien
nous nous protégeons tous et c'est cela
que j'ai demandé au policier ou gendarme
j'entends que jean bien su r me trouve
peu claires il ya une différence entre
le fait d'être peu claires et de ne pas
dire ce que l'on a envie d'entendre
donc dans la question de jean-pierre
sueur je sens qu'elle serait sa réponse
et je ne doute pas que s'il était en
responsabilité et n'aurait aucune
difficulté dans le marasme mondial que
nous avons connue de trouver des masques
moi je sais que je fais avec la
disponibilité que nous avons et que nous
avons fait le choix c'est celui de
protéger les personnels de santé qui
sont immédiatement mobilisés
au service et pour sauver les français
ensuite que je sais aussi c'est que nous
avons très tôt équiper l'ensemble des
véhicules
l'ensemble des sites d'accueil de
masques de gel et que nous avons élargi
à d'autres matériels comme des lunettes
la protection que nous devons à nos
forces
si la doctrine devait évoluer notamment
sur les masques dits grand public par
exemple
évidemment nous nous adapterons et nous
la mettrons en oeuvre sans aucun état
d'âme et sans aucune hésitation
ma responsabilité est de mettre en
oeuvre une doctrine de défendre aussi
dans les discussions qui peuvent exister
les agents du ministère de l'intérieur
il sait ce que nous faisons ce que je
peux noter là c'est que il y à des
agents du ministère de l'intérieur qui
sont décédés atteint du co lead aucun
n'était en contact avec le public dans
la police la préfecture de police dans
la préfectorale
aucun été directement en contact et
pourtant atteint aussi ducobu 19 et nous
avons le regret de comme tout le pays
d'accompagner nos morts et je sais aussi
les combats qui sont menées par certains
de nos agents qui sont malades où je
vous parle je vais reprendre les
questions je vais tenter de le faire
dans l'ordre d'abord sur la question de
la sénatrice stage prignaud évidemment
la continuité de l'activité
d'applications agent nommé nationale est
au coeur de notre engagement
mais on a modifié certaines choses et
commissariats sont moins ouverts donc il
ya une centralisation de l'accueil au
public
l'idée de limiter les points de contact
par contre nous n'avons pas baissé le
nombre de policiers présents et nous
avons au contraire souhaité qu'ils
soient dans la rue à proximité de tous
les besoins d'intervention d'urgence
qu'ils puissent connaître l'organisation
de la continuité de l'activité s'est
fait dans le cadre d'un plan de
continuité d'activité et qui évidemment
prévoit que l'activité classique de la
police se poursuivre les enquêtes
judiciaires la sécurité routière
évidemment il ya moins de monde sur les
routes mais on a constaté une
augmentation des très grands excès de
vitesse et donc j'ai quelques jours
encore demandé à nos forces de sécurité
de préparer un plan d'action pour lutter
contre les très grands excès de vitesse
et et en particulier pour le week-end
prochain
parce que la route et ont libéré on voit
des comportements qui ne sont pas des
portes comportement acceptable
puis je pense aussi à tout le volet je
rejoins des sujets que nous avons abordé
de renseignements et de prévention de
lutte contre le terrorisme ou le
séparatisme sur lesquels nos services
sont totalement mobilisés aussi on a
changé l'organisation du temps de
travail je l'aï dit tout à l'heure en
particulier au sein de la police avec
moins de présence dans la durée
hebdomadaire de travail pour arriver à
assurer une continuité de présence avec
l'ensemble de nos forces
c'est un schéma d'organisation que nous
avons mis en place et qui prend en
compte aussi la difficulté de l'exercice
tel qu'il est posé aujourd'hui pour pour
nos forces
vous avez évoqué les violences
intrafamiliales qui sont évidemment un
sujet de préoccupation majeur majeur
pourquoi parce que personne ici ne peut
accepter que le confinement et
l'enfermement subies par des enfants ou
par un conjoint ou une conjointe le plus
souvent soit synonyme d'impunité face à
un père conjoint un beau père je vais
pas faire la liste violon
et nous sommes dans un paradoxe où le
nombre de plaintes déposées baissent
significativement mais évidemment nous
sommes convaincus qu'il ya une
augmentation des violences
intrafamiliales
on a un indicateur l'indicateur revanche
je vous parle c'est celui du nombre
d'interventions à domicile de nos forces
de l'ordre gendarmerie nationale police
nationale et préfecture de police depuis
le début du confinement le 16 mars
nous nous avons augmenté les
interventions à domicile alors je
précise bien ses interventions à
domicile c'est la première fois que j'ai
donné ce chiffre ça s'est traduit par
l'augmentation des vifs
ça n'est pas le cas c'est un indicateur
mais de 48%
c'est significatif on a aussi
l'augmentation du nombre de chat sur la
plate forme que nous avons mis en place
il ya un peu plus d'un an pour dénoncer
les violences sexuelles et sexistes
cette plateforme où on communique de
façon anonyme et puis vous avez en face
de vous un policier un gendarme selon
l'endroit où vous habitez que vous avez
indiquée qui va vous conduire vers le
dépôt de plainte mais au départ c'est
anonyme donc c'est plus facile
là on a une augmentation très
significative c'était multiplié par 14
ça ne veut pas dire là aussi qu' on a
abouti à chaque fois à 14 fois plus de
plaintes ou de prêts plainte en ligne
parce que les gens étant chez eux vont
aussi plus facilement sur ce chat là
mais c'est quand même un indicateur de
problèmes que nous connaissons et je
vous donnais chiffres en 2019 on a eu 54
échanges en moyenne pour des violences
intrafamiliales en 2020 gens nous sommes
à 759 chat relatifs à cela donc on voit
bien qu'il ya un problème et c'est la
raison pour laquelle avec mes collègues
du gouvernement
on s'est mobilisé pour faire en sorte
que tous les moyens d'appeler au secours
soit possible parce que c'est plus
difficile d'appeler le 17 si le conjoint
violent est à côté de vous évidemment
c'est plus difficile d'aller au
commissariat si le conjoint est toujours
avec vous et donc on a essayé de faire
en sorte que nous puissions de façon
dématérialisée sur la plateforme que je
viens d'évoquer
j'ai mobilisé s'était d'ailleurs je vais
citer à l'époque je le cite volontiers
un échange que j'ai vu avec laurent
wauquiez président de la région auvergne
rhône-alpes
j'ai mobilisé 214 214 numéro de
téléphone qui était dédiée aux personnes
malentendantes
mais qui nous a permis en fait par texto
de donner l'alerté en se disant si une
personne a un téléphone ne peut pas
téléphoner appeler le 17
ou le 39 19 pour se faire accompagner
elle peut aussi elle va aux toilettes en
cachette envoyé un texto d'urgence nous
traitons 170 appels
enfin textos par jour grâce au 114 j'ai
mis en place ce dispositif il montre son
efficacité
je n'ai pas les chiffres sur le nombre
de personnes interpellées dans ce cadre
là mais nous les aurons et je vous les
communiquerons volontiers nous avons
élargi oc dans des lieux différents vous
avez évoqué les pharmacies que j'avais
négocié avec la présidente de l'ordre
des pharmaciens sur un modèle espagnol
c'était une initiative des associations
espagnoles j'en avais eu connaissance et
j'ai appelé la présidente de l'ordre
pour lui proposer ce pas et les
pharmaciens ont tout de suite joué le
jeu je sais au moment où je vous parle
j'ai au moins quatre personnes
interpellées dans le cadre d'un
signalement on va dire pharmacie marlène
schiappa à développer aussi des
présences des permanences dans quelques
centres commerciaux sur lequel on a là
des gens qui vous accompagne et qui
peuvent vous aider à donner l'alerté
aussi on a essayé du coup d'avoir tous
ces dispositifs une plateforme de
logements sans compter les moyens donnés
aux associations mais aussi la
possibilité d'accueillir les d'ouvrir le
financement de 20 mille nuitées
financées dans le cadre du budget de
marlène schiappa pour faire en sorte
qu'on puisse accueillir des femmes ou
des hommes violents
et voilà et je peux vous dire que j'ai
donné des instructions très claires au
préfet c'est que je ne veux pas entendre
parler pour le matériel si jamais on a
besoin des bergers qui que ce soit en
urgence aujourd'hui une vraie question
dont des hôtels
chaque fois que c'est nécessaire pour
loger des gens qui sont dans la rue et
pas question qu'un préfet puisse me dire
ah non mais on n'avait pas la bonne
ligne budgétaire
je pense que le message a vraiment été
passé pour que nous puissions sur ce
dispositif est totalement totalement
engagée ce ne sont que quelques exemples
et je peux vous dire ce que nous avons
voulu j'ai même poussé aussi où j'ai
accompagné parce que je veux pas
revendiquer cela une proposition qui
avait été faite par le dggn élargi au
dgpn
les appels d'initiative c'est à dire que
nous connaissons certaines familles ul
détention mais il n'y a pas eu de dépôt
de plainte il ya pas eu de sanctions
judiciaires
mais il ya peut-être un risque j'ai
demandé à nos forces de faire des appels
d'initiative de téléphoner et
d'apprécier la situation
jean pierre sueur
interrogé sur la capacité d'un policier
après c'est une situation mal à quand
ils appellent ils sont au son de la voix
qui est un problème
nous avons interpellé plusieurs
conjoints violents dans ce cadre là donc
on essaye vraiment de faire en sorte que
tous les dispositifs puissent être
utilisés parce qu'on sait que
l'enfermement c'est un risque de
violence et que s'il ya risque de
violences il faut évidemment que nous
puissions réagir très vite tout jour
j'ai pas finir mais c'est alors si vous
acceptez mathieu demy nisation de ses
plus vives sur les pharmaciens
commerciaux ce qui serait pas
intéressant que les préfets la liste des
pharmacies concernées par une par
département tout parce que nous on
n'arrive pas à résoudre dans le
département je connais bien on n'arrive
pas à voir cette lisibilité là parce que
ça permet aussi de faire des relais les
maires ils peuvent faire des relais
enfin voila je pense que c'est très
important de relayer cette information
parce que vous vous dites tout mais est
ce que tout le font vraiment est ce que
toutes ont la capacité de le faire parce
que c'est pas si simple c'est important
des lieux d'écouté mais c'est donc du
coup est ce que vous nous dites toutes
les pharmacies de fond ou est ce qu'il y
à du volontariat j'ai envie de dire ce
que c'est ça la lisibilité est ce qu'on
peut dire aux femmes toutes les
pharmacies sont censés vous écoutez en
cas de problème bon voilà je vais
inversée votre question je n'imagine pas
un pharmacien en france qui est
sollicité par une femme et qui lui dit
s'il vous plaît aidez-moi appelé police
secours qu'il ne le fasse pas et quand
j'ai travaillé sur cette idée avec la
présidente de l'ordre des pharmaciens
on s'est pas posé cette question là
parce qu'elle savait que personne ne
seraient dans cette situation là il
s'agit pas de dire on va protéger
physiquement etc il s'agit juste en
espagne il ya même eu un code c'est la
personne venait disait je veux un masque
19 à ce moment là le pharmacien prend le
nom laisse partir la personne et appelle
la police pour dire j'ai une alerte il
ya madame untel qui habite à temps
l'endroit j'ai leur donnant ce qui m'a
demandé un masque 19 ça n'existe pas et
donc ces voix là mais évidemment je n'ai
pas fait la publicité sur masque 19 pour
que sinon ça perdait tout sens c'était
les associations qui avaient fait ce pas
voilà je je je pense que c'est pas à
100% efficace
hélas mais c'est vraiment l'idée de dire
on s'offrent tous les moyens possibles
le 114 est un dispositif qui ne pourra
pas durer
sous la forme du 114 parce que c'est le
centre
allier universitaire de grenoble qu'ils
gèrent ils n'ont pas la possibilité dans
la durée de le faire ils ont accepté de
le faire mais j'ai demandé à nos
services de faire en sorte que ce
dispositif soit pérennisé ensuite et que
la plateforme que nous avons contre les
violences puissent demain traités par
chat mais puissent aussi traiter les
textos voilà mes jeux de questions et je
vois pas la prétention de vous dire le
problème est réglé je crains hélas qui
ne soit pas réglé et je peux parler des
appels pour les violences faites aux
femmes et aux enfants mais elles sont
nombreuses aussi ces violences là et
c'est un sujet sur lequel nous sommes
mobilisés mais les consignes ont été
données d'être plus vigilants en cas
voudrais conclure ma réponse sur ce
sujet en vous rappelant que chaque jour
en france
or confinement ce sont 200 femmes qui
sont accompagnés par les services de
police et gendarmerie de sens alors je
sais qu' il peut y avoir une polémique
parce qu'on peut y avoir un trou dans la
raquette et peut y avoir une erreur
d'appréciation il peut y avoir une
mauvaise gestion
ce que je n'aime pas c'est qu'on mette
en cause du coup tout le système
policier où tout le système des
gendarmes quand je sais que chaque jour
200 femmes sont accompagnées dans ce
cadre là et combien sont sauvés par viel
je ne sais pas mais c'est quand même
assez significatif vous avez évoqué le
le sujet que j'avais traité du repli
communautaire j'ai évoqué le repli
communautaire et le risque non pas
immédiat d'habitude je vais commencer
par l'immédiateté les risques dans les
quartiers je vais vous dire oui il ya
des exemples donnés citer quelques-uns
de violences urbaines
hélas ce n'est pas exceptionnel hélas
est globalement ou non je vous parle je
mets une grande prudence sa dette
ça n'a pas été le cas par an entre la
nuit de samedi à dimanche où on a eu un
nombre d'incidents lourd si ce qui me
sont remontés
parce que beaucoup par contre
globalement la situation dans les
quartiers est plutôt calme par rapport à
nos statistiques habituelles aux
tensions mais il n'empêche pas que liées
à des faits et que le moindre fait le
moindre guet-apens la moindre agression
contre nos forces de sécurité intérieure
ou contre les pompiers restent vrais
problèmes et nous devons nous mobiliser
sur le sujet
on arrive on a observé ces derniers
jours un certain relâchement dans les
quartiers n'est pas que dans les
quartiers
je prenais des nouvelles d'un frère
médecin lierrois entière qui injecte
dans la ville de man à sa plus grande
ville de mon département mais qui compte
vingt mille habitants
donc vous voyez c'est le don du rural
comme médecin et trouvez qu'il n'y avait
pas de respect de règles de confinement
et on n'est pas dans des quartiers donc
le relâchement on le sent bien et on le
sent aussi dans les quartiers il ya eu
des épisodes violents ça n'est pas la
règle est globalement que ce soit dans
les comportements classique que ce soit
dans les messages données par les
autorités religieuses
il ya vraiment un niveau de conscience
assez élevé et je veux pas laisser
penser que les jeunes des quartiers
seraient plus coulants que la moyenne et
se dirait que eux sont invincibles non
je crois qu'ils font vraiment attention
aussi à cette dimension là par contre
j'ai évoqué effectivement pas forcément
immédiatement mais les risques de sortie
du confinement dans la liste de sortie
du confinement je pense qu'il ya d'abord
avant la sortie du confinement la perte
que j'évoquais de l'adhésion progressive
de la population et donc c'est un risque
en soi et à les tensions et les troubles
à l'ordre public qui monte en puissance
et ça peut exister c'était les
mutineries dans des prisons des
résistances dans les cra j'ai une
question de jean-pierre sueur j'y
reviendrai tout à l'heure on sent bien
que plus le confinement dur plus
l'exercice est difficile plus des
tensions sont possibles et peuvent
exister il ya les autres formes de
délinquance je réponds peut-être par des
questions qui viendront tout à l'heure
mais on voit bien aussi comment dans la
sortie du confinement il nous faudra
gérer la reprise de la hausse de
l'activité criminelle
on voit aussi comment elle s'adapte
notamment vers la cybercriminalité et
j'ai une très forte multiplication des
des prêts plaintes ou des signalements
sur des la cyber délinquance qui
évidemment existent voire des cyber
attaques sur des centres hospitaliers
pour vous dire la délinquance elle
s'adapte et elle se dit qu'effectivement
faire rançonner un hôpital aujourd'hui
basse ça peut être plus rentable qu'à
d'autres moments et donc on a eu des
attaques auxquelles nous n'étions pas
habitués sur ce sujet là mais c'est
plutôt tout la hausse des escroqueries
par internet escroquerie à l'achat sur
lequel on a une augmentation et sur le
communautarisme
j'ai évoqué deux risques le premier
c'est celui du fait que ceux qui veulent
développer une organisation
communautaire profite du phénomène de
repli sur soi que nous connaissons mais
puisse jouer en fait sur un discours de
victimisation discours de victimisation
qui est jeu prendre l'exemple de la
proche du ramadan de 10 ans t'empêche de
te protège pas dans ton quartier tu vas
être victime du clos vide on empêche le
pratiquer le ramadan comme tu devrais le
pratiquer notamment la rupture du jeûne
les rassemblements etc et donc vient
vers moi c'est ça le discours procès dit
que j'ai évoquée est que nous pouvons
craindre ces raisons pour laquelle j'ai
demandé au préfet que ils maintiennent
la permanence notamment dclear qu'ont
été mises en place pour qu'on puisse
rester attentif sur ces sujets là il ya
des volets qui sont tombés celui vous a
dit on à une action tout azimuts sur ce
sujet s'cusez moi je suis trop long je
sais vous c'est passionné je le suis
aussi
je vais tenter d'être plus qu après il
ya toute action qui venait contrer
commercial commerces ont fermé
donc du coup on n'a plus forcément
besoin de les faire fermer d'utiliser
d'autres règles mais il n'empêche que il
faut rester attentif sur cela et qu'il
ya un commerce informel qui se constitue
à côté donc j'ai demandé aussi qu'on
puisse
travailler sur cela est-ce que nous
sommes parfaits non parce qu'il faut
répondre à toutes les sollicitations
mais le risque il est là et le risque
que j'expliquais de proses et de
discours prosélyte east c'est ce
discours qui pourrait dire tu vois tu es
une victime abandonné et ont t'empêche
de croire le salut y compris le salut
médicale vous savez que la médecine
prophétique s'est développée ces
dernières années le salut médical passe
par leur religion entre refuse de bien
appliquer la région et tu ne peux pas
aller qui à l'église il ya une messe
samedi soir organisée dans une église
parisienne je n'arrive pas à comprendre
comment on peut être aussi idiots
excusez moi mais pour faire cela ou une
mosquée enfin vous m'avez interrogé sur
les extrêmes oui il ya une agitation sur
les réseaux ensuite il ya une note qui a
été interprétée par un journal qu'il a
reprise dimanche au journal national et
parisien
et puis j'ai vu qu'un hebdomadaire
l'avait repris aussi il y à une
agitation autant de la mobilisation
d'ultra-droite de l'ultra-gauche chez
demandé à nos services d'être très
attentifs à cela est de se préparer
il ya eu quelques actes trois attentats
contre des trois atteinte à des pilotes
une atteinte à un mcdonald's ces
derniers jours qu'ils sont des actes
dont on sait qu'ils sont ciblés hélas
pas nouveau mais ça veut dire qu'il nous
faut être sur ce sujet particulièrement
attentifs
l'ultra droite est très mobilisé sur les
réseaux mais je ne mets pas en tête
d'acte particulier elle que je pourrais
évoquer devant vous et puis j les jeunes
nous disent qu elles seront mobilisés à
la sortie du confinement les syndicats
certains ont appelé aussi à des grèves
autant de sujets sur lequel nous faudra
être positionné sur le terrorisme je
finis sur ce sujet là le risque est
permanent
nous leur enverrons mis sur lausanne il
n'y a pas d' alerte particulière liée à
la période que nous connaissons hélas on
vit avec la permanence du risque et on
ne sait pas comment surtout qu'on s'est
endogène et que c'est une personne qui
d'un coup passe actuellement l'effet du
confinement y compris psychologique peut
aussi déclencher des actes graves qui
peuvent être liés à une pratique
terroristes ou pas mais là dessus on est
sur un autre sujet je crois avoir abordé
toutes vos questions je vais venir à
sète
jean pierre sueur sur les masques que je
les dis sur les cartes davud garde à vue
j'ai un chiffre qui doit être pris avec
la distance de la remontée des
informations mais j'ai un chiffre de
1733 gardes à vue prises dans le cadre
de réitération
ensuite il ya une très large palette de
suite donné par le parquet sur lequel je
n'ai pas de visibilité particulière
c'est un point à travailler avec la
garde des sceaux et peut-être que si
vous initiaux n'est la garde des sceaux
elle pourra vous éclairer sur sur ce
sujet là je ne sais pas si c'est dans
votre nous avons auditionné lagarde a
partout la semaine dernière d'accord bon
alors mais pas avec le recul qu'on a il
se mettrait car tout va très vite oui
mais c'est un set un tableau de bord si
je lai que je vous communiquerai
monsieur le président et je pense qu'il
est intéressant de vos devoirs cela il
ya la question des drones jeu sueur m'a
fait l'amitié de milhas vous avez
annoncé vous avez dit non j'ai rien
annoncer je n'ai rien dit je me suis pas
exprimé encore sur ce sujet mais je vais
le faire devant vous je pense qu'il
visait le ministère de l'intérieur dans
le vous collectif voilà je voudrais
préciser que nous avons actuellement 400
drones en service dans la police et de
la gendarmerie
c'est un outil particulièrement
nécessaire utile et efficace qui nous
permet de renforcer nos moyens et c'est
un dispositif qui va monter en puissance
comme dans l'armée on sait combien ils
montent en puissance ce sont je rappelle
des aéronefs dont la police gendarmerie
est habilité à les utiliser
depuis le 17 décembre 2015
et c'est dans ce cadre là que nous
faisons et donc il ya eu l'année
dernière
la décision de monter en puissance de
renouveler du matériel
une commande qui a été préparée initiés
qui n'a strictement rien à voir avec
l'épidémie parce qu'elle a été décidée
bien avant que le caïd apparaissent même
en chine et donc je crois qu'au delà de
l'emballement médiatique il ne serait
pas sage de laisser penser qu'il y ait
un lien quelconque
de toute façon ce que l'on peut
souhaiter c'est que ces aéronefs
commandées soit opérationnel à un moment
où nous ne serons plus en gestion d'une
crise aussi profonde que celle que nous
connaissons concernant le coc vide donc
voilà c'est les sciences l'échéance de
des appels d'offres qui veut cela mais
cela dit les drones peuvent être
utilisés dans le contrôle du confinement
et je l'assumé parfaitement devant vous
nous utilisons des hélicoptères par
exemple pour contrôler les plages et la
présence sur des plages des avions et
donc je pense que c'est un moyen plus
économique et je ne ne très pas à nos
services à possibilité d'utiliser des
drones pour ensuite avoir une
intervention évident physique personnel
et un contrôle parce qu'il ya pas de
verbalisation à partir de drones
c'est le sens de votre question seul
président c'est le sens de la question
du fanny vous posez monsieur le ministre
je crois que c'est très important de
bien le rappeler et de rappeler aussi
que des images prises par des drones qui
ont accès évidemment à ce qui se passe
dans des jardins privés ne peuvent pas
non plus être exploitées par les forces
de sécurité au milieu des verbalisations
évidemment ni même à des visites au
domicile des des événements qui se
seraient produits sur des lieux privés
dans d'autres cadres j'aurais peut-être
pu prendre le risque de dire cela mais
face à vous monsieur le président on
propose se voulait nécessairement
extrêmement prudent et respectueux des
libertés publiques
c'est un compliment ce rendez-vous quand
cela parce que je sais combien vous êtes
vigilants sur ce genre rosit de plaisir
voilà temps insisté sur le fait que la
verbalisation par nature est toujours
humaine sur ces sujets là j'ai une autre
question de monsieur concerne la
régularisation des étrangers me dit vous
ne souhaitez pas régularisée j'applique
à priori la même politique que celle
qu'il soutenait il ya quelques années je
rien que c'est une circulaire qui
prévoit un certain nombre de régulation
nous n'avons pas modifié et évidemment
nous la menthe ou non mais je sais qu'il
ya une petite polémique depuis quelques
semaines parce que il ya une
communication portugaise sur des
régulations des étrangers sans titre aux
accès de soins avec au portugal il ya
même une pétition signée par quelques
parlementaires notamment invitant à
faire la même chose je vais être
extrêmement clair je dirais volontiers
chiche
et si nous ne l'avons pas fait et si le
portugais a dû le faire c'est que le
dispositif que nous avons déjà en place
permettait de ne pas avoir besoin de
faire ce que le portugal a fait parce
que ça n'était pas en place je pense que
je suis claire en vous disant cela mais
en gros c'était pour l'ensemble des
demandeurs d'asile au portugal qui était
arrivé avant le 18 mars d'avoir et qui
n'a pas fait de titres de demande de
titre de séjour d'avoir une autorisation
temporaire de présence sur place et
d'avoir du coup dans ce cadre de ce
statut de la administratif
l'accès aux soins il se trouve qu'en
france les étrangers
quel que soit leur statut administratif
disposent d'un accès au système de santé
prise en charge par la collectivité
s'agissant des soins urgents
les demandeurs d'asile bénéficient eux
de l'axé la sécurité sociale de droit
commun et des soins urgents de santé
sont donc assurés pour tous par contre
nous avons la situation de droit qui
peuvent être ouverts et donc autant nous
avons fermé les services d'accueil dans
les préfectures mais nous avons prévu
une permanence d'accès pour toutes les
situations particulières qui nous
seraient signalés notamment par les
associations pour pouvoir
istres et et ouvrir les droits à ceux
qui n'auraient pas été enregistrés
précédemment
et donc je le dis très clairement une
mesure temporaire d'accès au séjour pour
assurer l'accès au droit pour les
étrangers comme le portugal a fait n'est
pas nécessaire dans notre pays parce que
nous avions un dispositif qui était au
moins aussi efficace sur le sujet sally
terrain je parle je ne peux pas juger le
choix portugais mais c'est vrai que j'ai
lu avec intérêt la pétition parce que le
titre qui avait été donnée par la
communication portugaise avait pu
laisser penser qu'il ya une politique
différente et c'est vrai que ça m'a
interrogé j'ai interrogé les services et
j'étais rassuré de voir que nous avions
mise en place cela se fait m'interroger
sur l'engorgement du 17
il est vrai que nous avons connu des
augmentations des appels au 17 27% à
marseille par exemple 76% en seine et
marne 39 % d'augmentation
a lille c'est pour saluer le président
caennais re que j'évoque ce territoire
là mais j'ai commencé par marseille
voudrait pas monsieur le président
et donc du coup on a renforcé les moyens
on a créé un chat spécifique à côté du
17 qui n'existaient pas pour alléger
aussi la pression sur le 17 parce qu'il
n'est pas possible qu'ils aiment tant
d'attentes trop long sur le 17 et donc
pour toutes les sollicitations qui ne
relève pas de l'urgence
normalement le 17 devrait être que le
numéro de l'urgence nous avons fait en
sorte qu'on puisse savoir cela j'ai
d'ailleurs eu l'occasion de m'exprimer
là quelques jours sur un maire qui
invitait ses administrés à dénoncer les
gens qui selon lui eux ne respectent pas
le confirme en appelant le 17 nov map
les pales 17 le 17 doit être un numéro
d'urgence par contre il ya un chat qui a
déjà fait l'objet de 29 mille saisi par
la peau ni veau de la police nationale
et qui permet de répondre de répondre à
cela donc on essaye vraiment de faire
face mais savait qu'on a connu une
augmentation importante du sujet jean
perçu un mot s'est interrogé sur les cra
nous continuons à éloigner est donc
actuellement je crois qu'on est à moins
de 150 personnes qui sont dans les cra
sur une capacité d'accueil dix fois
supérieur donc nous savons aussi gérer
le confinement et la protection
sanitaire
il ya eu un cas qui m'ont été signifiée
d'une personne atteinte du coc vite dans
les cra et qui évidemment été prise en
charge d'un point de vue médical
je ne souhaite pas les fermer je vous le
dis devant vous parce que ceux qui sont
principalement aujourd'hui pour 80% dans
des cra sont des sortants de prison et
que les fermes et c'est accepter que son
contrôle et par décision unilatérale du
ministre de l'intérieur et puisse être
remis en liberté le juge de la détention
peut le décider sur des instructions
individuelles le conseil d'état a été
saisi et a considéré que les conditions
de gestion des cra aujourd'hui par nos
services
ne mettez pas en cause et ne mettez pas
en risque sanitaire
ce qui était dans nos crânes donc
aujourd'hui moi je reste sur ce sujet là
parce que je sais que si jamais une
personne qui était
éloigné du cra parce que je décidé de
façon unilatérale de le faire mais sans
prendre de mesures de protection et qui
commettra un acte grave je ne manquerai
pas je ne doute pas que certains
pourraient me le reprocher y compris ce
qui m'interroge aujourd'hui sur les
fermetures de crâne et donc je vous le
dis l'objectif c'est de poursuivre des
reconduites à la frontière chaque fois
que c'est possible avec des pays où
évidemment il n'y a pas de risque
particulier d'un point de vue sanitaire
ou pas plus de risques que te proposer à
quelqu'un de sortir d'un crâne de le
laisser dans la nature y compris quand
il n'a pas de logement
et la dernière question sa sortie du
confinement je ne présiderai plec a
demandé au gouvernement de présenter des
préconisations sous quinze jours donc
maintenant sous 13 jauge de pâques la
question des personnes en fragilité ou
la personne la question des personnes
âgées je ne fais pas le lien forcément
entre les deux sera traité dans ce cadre
là et que jean pierre sueur a tous les
éléments de réponse dans ce dossier qui
ne relèvent pas du ministère de
l'intérieur
merci de ses réponses monsieur le
ministre nous allons passer aux étapes
suivantes de notre audition et sortir du
terrain de du contrôle du confinement
mais avant cela je vais vous poser une
ultime question qui renvoie à ce que je
disais en ouvrant cette audition vous
avez vous même assisté sur le
discernement que vous attendez des
agents de police et de gendarmerie dans
la manière dont il dresse procès verbal
pour les infractions au confinement
mais il faut reconnaître que cette
exigence elle est plus forte qu'à
l'ordinaire car il ya un certain nombre
de sanctions qui jusqu'à présent ne
pouvait être prononcée que par un
tribunal avec une appréciation des
circonstances qui est forcément fait
avec un peu de recul par rapport à
l'infraction qui qui qui a été commise
et ses situations aujourd'hui donnent
lieu à des amendes forfaitaires c'est à
dire à une sanction automatique en
quelque sorte
il s'agit notamment des contraventions
dit de 5e classe qui sont prononcés pour
quelqu'un qui a récidivé en violant les
règles du confinement et c'est là qu'on
voit et ça n'est pas tout à fait
marginal qu'il y a de la part des agents
verbalisateurs d
pratique qui gagnerait à être unifiée je
cite des exemples le cas où à la sortie
d'un supermarché en demande de tickets
de caisse pas de ticket de caisse procès
verbal est ce que c'est normal le cas où
on vérifie le contenu du caddie est-ce
que c'est permis
le cas où considère que des gâteaux qui
ont été achetés ne sont pas des aliments
essentiels et où on verbalise le cas où
quelqu'un fait ses courses à bicyclette
peut-être n'ad'ailleurs t'il pas de
voiture et on le verbalisent parce que
il a fait ses courses à bicyclette le
cas où on verbalise parce que une
personne n'est pas allé au supermarché
le plus proche mais un supermarché situé
à 5 km et vous voyez que ce discernement
que vous demandez dans l'appréciation
des faits et que quand même mérite sans
doute d'être davantage encadré est-ce
que vous avez aujourd'hui suffisamment
de remonter sur ses différences
d'approché
les procureurs font état de ces
différentes approches aussi qui rend
rendent plus difficile leur propre
travail ensuite
est-ce que vous avez des remontées
suffisante sur ces différentes approches
pour que ça justifie de votre part des
initiatives pour mieux cadrer l'exercice
de la sanction par nos policiers et nos
gendarmes et pour que au fond les
français sachent vraiment à quoi s'en
tenir sur des choses aussi concrète
simple et pratique que celle que j'ai
rapporté
je crois que vu les conséquences
nous devons effectivement veiller à ce
que le discernement soit respectée et
soient bien appliquées et donc c'est une
règle ce que je voudrais dire c'est que
j'ai évoqué les 12,5 millions de
contrôles tout à l'heure le nombre de
cas qui nous sont remontées sont faibles
mais avec la dynamique des réseaux
sociaux évidemment vous en entendez
parler mais moi aussi et je suis très
actif sur les réseaux sociaux en
vigilance j'y passe de nombreuses heures
par jour et surtout par nuit pas trop de
pas trop tout de même monsieur le
ministre j'espère que le social je passe
beaucoup je dors peu et donc je passe
beaucoup de temps à suivre l'actualité
des réseaux sociaux et chaque fois que
je vois ce qui apparaît une anomalie je
demande systématiquement une enquête
pour comprendre ce que je sais c'est que
il y à une plateforme de saisine de
l'igpn ou si vous avez un désaccord avec
un contrôle vous pouvez le signaler
je vais 2.5 millions de contrôles que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure il ya eu 160
si je suis pas à jour aujourd'hui
réclamation déposée qui mènent quand
même à une proportion alors ça ne veut
pas dire qu'il ya eu que 166 cas
contestable ce qu'il veut pas dire
d'ailleurs
cent soixante six erreurs ne peut y
avoir beaucoup plus mais tout le monde
n'a pas en tête qu'il peut faire ce
signalement sur la plate forme et je
trouve que c'est un chiffre qui est
assez intéressant et qui montrent que
finalement il ya eu pas de cap
quelquefois j'ai lu sur les réseaux
sociaux par exemple qu'on avait
verbalisé à lyon un sdf parce qu'il
n'était pas à son domicile
j'ai immédiatement demandé une enquête
j'ai même été saisie par des
associations etc s'étaient relayés par
des responsables éminente de la classe
politique pour constater que tout ça
était un fake
bon mais je ne doute pas qu'ils aient
des erreurs parce que nous avons mis en
oeuvre des dispositifs large qui appelle
à ce discernement et donc dans la mise
en oeuvre et même dans la volonté de
bien faire de nos agents peut y avoir
des erreurs d'appréciation on a fait
très régulièrement
le dgpn le dggn et moi-même dans le
cadre de la cic des instructions ont
formalisé pour bien préciser ce qui
devait être contrôlé ce qu'ils ne
devaient pas l'être par exemple on ne
contrôle pas les courses
si par contre on pense que la personne
en face de vous mon gouvernement à
l'officier de police judiciaire
il a des moyens dans ce cadre là on n'a
pas vocation à contrôler les courses
et puis j'ai lu par exemple ne comprends
pas ce que vous voulez dire quand on
fait un contrôle on n'a pas vocation à
fouiller la voiture de quelqu'un pour
vérifier qu'il a fait ses courses dans
la ligue encore frais oui j'ai compris
les corses pardon d'où ma surprise
monsieur le ministre comme vous le
répéter à deux reprises et que je les
malentendus deux fois de suite je me
suis dit qu'il fallait absolument que je
que je que je règle cette difficulté
mais là le prenions un risque
risque à ne pas lever cette ambiguïté et
donc du coup ces instructions sont
formalisées elles sont mises à jour la
dernière mise à jour pour ce qui me
concerne on remonte au 6 avril et essaie
d'encadrer cela mais parce que je sais
que peut faire des erreurs
d'appréciation g veiller aussi à ce que
le délai de recours contre les
constatations et les infractions les
procès verbaux passe de 45 à 90 jours
que nous puissions vraiment être sorti
de la période du confinement et que nous
puissions prendre le temps d'examiner
cela et je peux vous dire que ce soit
dans les réunions de préfet que je fais
chaque soin que ce soit par les dg de
gpn dggn ou préfet de police il ya des
rappels réguliers qui sont faits sur ce
sujet mais de la même façon on a fait
évoluer notre doctrine au début par
exemple on a eu des cas où tous les
professionnels du transport
pas tous mais certains étaient
systématiquement empêchées donc il a
fallu qu'on rappelle que le confinement
n'empêchait pas les professionnels du
transport de se déplacer et donc on a
souvent eu aussi des fédérations
professionnelles qui nous ont saisis
donc on a toujours veillé à essayer
d'adapter la règle sans dénaturer
l'enjeu du confinement mais de s'adapter
à cela
voilà et s'il ya des erreurs
d'interprétation il faut les contester
et ça ne se passait pas moi qui serai
l'officier du ministère public
mais ce sera évidemment prises en compte
nous sommes sur une mise en oeuvre
pragmatique qui porte sa part de risque
bien sûr et l'essentiel est évidemment
que le contrôle du confinement soit bien
assurée d'ailleurs la plupart des
français n'ont pas besoin de se
contrôler pour le respecter c'est avant
tout la discipline collective qui
explique que le confinement est respecté
mais le nombre de contrôler le nombre
d'infractions vous avez relevé montre
quand même qu'il y à une minorité de nos
concitoyens qui
tant besoin néanmois de ces contrôles
alors nous allons passer maintenant à
des questions de madame delattre qui est
à ma droite et de monsieur buffet qui
est aussi à ma droite qui vont vous
posez des questions qui sont relatives
aux lieux privatifs de liberté je donne
d'abord la parole à madame delattre
merci monsieur président juste une
remarque sur les élections vous en
parlait en préambule dire que
effectivement l'installation des
conseils municipaux ne peut apparaître
comme non prioritaire mais pourtant il
sera déterminant dans la politique du
déconfinement donc nous avons tous en
tête le 23 mai mais je pense que nous
serions tous rassurés de savoir que vous
travaillez à des scénarii pour que ces
installations se fassent effectivement
rapidement sur l'approbation la semaine
dernière j'ai interrogé la garde des
sceaux sur les spip
nous avons eu des auditions encore hier
avec mon collègue français noël et je
pense que effectivement de façon
généralisée
le constat est fait que l'approbation ne
fonctionne plus en france il n'ya plus
au quasi plus de contrôle sur les
bracelets électroniques et la garde des
sceaux m'a répondu en terme peut être
plus plus sérieusement mais je vous
dirai en des termes un peu moins sérieux
peut-être circulez ya rien à voir
c'est à dire que elle m'a quand même
répondu les forces de l'ordre vérifie
dans la rue la réalité de ce confinement
je pense que ce n'est pas de votre rôle
c'est pas le rôle et de la police la
gendarmerie il ya des agents dans ces
spip qui souhaitent travailler qui
voudrait effectivement exercées ces
contrôles mais on ne leur donne pas les
moyens donc dans le cadre de l'aide de
la cellule de crise dont vous parliez
cette coopération interministérielle
avez vous eu à parler de cette probation
en panne en france ce qui paraît quand
même dommageable
cette période et ensuite vous parliez
aussi des crins le premier cas qui a été
signalé a été le 8 avril au cra de paris
vincennes quel a été le process est ce
que cette personne a été isolé est-ce
qu'on a des risques de clusters vous
parlez de 150 personnes est ce que son
sens que 50 personnes dekra est-ce que
vous ajoutez les locaux de rétention
administrative et les zones d'attentes
avez-vous de remontées particulières sur
ces dispositifs est ce que des médecins
passent tous les jours des gants des
masques sont des personnes qui ne
parlent pas forcément français
comment effectivement ça se passe dans
ses différents sites et enfin sur les
primes
on en a parlé beaucoup pierre sur les
primes accordées aux forces de l'ordre
et en pompier j'imagine qu'ils le feront
partie de ces agents qui seront
imprimées de quel ordre
et sur quels financements parlant depuis
le départ de pvs que la rentrée d'argent
des pv serait alors cela demande une
classification différentes mais pourrait
être fléché en priorité justement sur
ces primes forces de l'ordre et pompiers
ainsi que les soignants merci
merci monsieur le président monsieur
ministre pour continuer de parler des
centres de rétention administratif
j'aurais voulu savoir puisque vous avez
évoqué tout à l'heure le fait qu'il y
avait quatre que 80% des personnes qui
étaient en rétention
c'était en réalité des personnes sorties
de prison qu'elle est à peu près le taux
d'occupation aujourd'hui de nos centres
de rétention la deuxième chose c'est
les avocats ou les associations qui sont
présentes dans les centres de rétention
ils sont elles toujours six associations
la troisième chose étant le personnel
qui s'occupe de la gestion de centres de
rétention avec les personnels
pénitentiaires notamment est il
suffisamment équipés ou totalement
équipés pour assurer sa propre sécurité
sanitaire enfin la dernière question est
celle d éloignement puisque vous avez
évoqué le fait que les éloignements
continuer certes pas dans les
proportions que nous connaissons peu est
habituellement mais auquel cas ces
éloignements se font à quelle
destination
vers quel pays sont ils continuent et de
quelle manière ce sont les principales
questions que je souhaitais vous posez
cet après midi vous avez terminé
monsieur y aurait d'autres questions
mais qui touche mois à la prison là où à
la détention qu'à la sécurité et
notamment si vous le permettez monsieur
le président une question relative au
contrôle de nos frontières puisque dans
l'espace schengen
ah oui monsieur me c'est très important
de la question que s'apprête à poser par
là je ne sais je m'excuse de la question
portait sur la gestion actuelle de
l'espace schengen et les différents
moyens de contrôle qui sont placés à nos
frontières extérieures danser et qui
protège cet espace quels sont les moyens
mis en oeuvre les coopérations qui sont
mises en route j'imagine existe mais de
quelle nature sont elles et donc qu'est
ce qui est prévu à terme y at il un un
terme prévu à cette gestion
exceptionnelle des choses enfin dernier
point puisque femmes des micros mais
elle les derniers points c'est on évoque
beaucoup de potentiel je dis bien de
potentiel phénomène migratoire pouvant
venir d'autres continents en raison de
cette crise qui ce mondial l'avons
évoqué tout à l'heure comment de ce
point de vue là la france et l'europe
dans son temps son rôle de protection de
du territoire européen est elle à ce
jour organisée
merci monsieur ministre sioniste vous
avez la parole
merci sur les spip comme vous l'aviez sa
relève pas du ministère de l'intérieur
la seule chose que je peux vous indiquer
c'est que si dans un contrôle dans
fraction de confinement une personne est
constatée comme ayant un bracelet
électronique elle peut être contrôlée
dans ce cadre là mais elle n'est pas
parce qu'un bracelet électronique
ça n'est pas dans nos compétences et
nous sommes pas en charge chargés de ce
suivi de cela ça n'a pas été abordée en
cic répondre précisément à votre
question c'est un sujet que je pourrais
faire remonter à la garde des sceaux
échanger avec elle sur ce sujet à la
suite de votre intervention
plus globalement sur sur les cra alors
quelques éléments d'indication en fait
il ya quelques nationalité qu'il ya 132
retenu présent à ce jour
ça fait un peu moins de 10% de nos
capacités pour répondre à votre chiffre
et j'ai pris la décision d'en fermer
plusieurs parce qu'il restait que
quelques unités de personnes présentes
ya deux trois jours et donc du coup de
déplacer des gens qui sont retenus dans
le cadre de ces cra les quelques
nationalité il y en a six principalement
c'est l'albanie l'algérie le maroc le
portugal la roumanie ou la tunisie
ça n'est pas forcément sur ces pays où
il serait facile de procéder au monument
par contre il ya des géorgiens par
exemple sur lesquels l'état sanitaire de
la géorgie pourrait nous permettre et la
coopération avec ce pays de travailler
sur sur des retours dans ce cadre là où
il ya d'autres pays
la roumanie est assez pour présenter
aussi parmi les gens et la première
nationalité présente ce sont des
ressortissants algériens mais je prends
de cet exemple il n'est pas envisagée
dans l'immédiat de reconduite mais
n'empêche qu'ils sont toujours
techniquement possible et que nous
travaillons niveau consulaire avec
chacun de nos correspondants dans ces
pays sur les 132 retenue nous avons 89
sortant de prison soit 63% non 89 sur
132 ça fait pas ce sont trois ça fait
pas 63 ses dons ses 89 que j'ai 63% qui
relève des six nationalités je viens
d'évoquer
je suis pas clair si je leur fais simple
132 retenu 89 sortant de prison
voilà ça me paraît plus simple
et évidemment nous travaillons à spa et
on a des retours possibles avec
l'albanie la roumanie voir la georgie
que j'ai cités donc le taux d'occupation
s'est à peu près 10%
oui madame delà de nous fait une
suggestion que je ne souhaite pas
retenir mais je vais répondre au fond je
pense que ce serait une erreur
d'imaginer que nous puissions dire
l'argent des procès verbaux va être
affecté à une prime pour les policiers
les gendarmes
j'ai même peur que ça se retourne contre
nous et que ça ne permettent pas
d'atteindre l'objet d'objectifs
alors après je veux dire je ne sais pas
quel sera le volume global des sommes
perçues dans le cadre des procès verbaux
dressés
mais c'est sans commune mesure avec
l'engagement de l'état aujourd'hui pour
accompagner cette crise c'est presque en
proportion on est extrêmement éloignée
de la situation de nos engagements
financiers
mais je trouve que symboliquement
chercher à avoir une affectation même si
on n'est pas sur des taxes affectées
mais symboliquement on cherchait une
affectation pourrait avoir du sens et je
prends votre question dans cet esprit là
mais je ne suggérerai pas cela plus
concrètement vous posez la question des
efforts de sécurité intérieure comment
va être mise en oeuvre cette
reconnaissance ça n'est pas déterminée
au moment présent
gérald darmanin a présenté le dispositif
qui s'appliquera à l'ensemble de la
fonction publique qui ne vise pas être
une prime pour tous les fonctionnaires
mais qui vise être une prime qui doit
reconnaître en distinguant les
personnels du sanitaire et du social y
compris les collectivités locales et des
personnels de l'administration pour
prendre en compte un niveau d'engagement
exceptionnelle avec la possibilité que
cette prime soit modulé de 300 600 aux
mille euros par exemple ça n'ait pas été
arbitré pour l'instant nous devons faire
des scénarii que nous présenterons au
ministère des comptes publics
et c'est dans ce cadre là que je
présenterai aussi le dispositif au cf mg
pour les gendarmes et aux syndicats pour
les policiers et nous sommes à peine en
train de commencer à travailler sur ce
sujet là vous avez évoqué les pompiers
je rappelle que pour les agents de la
sécurité civile qui relève du ministère
de l'intérieur
comme je l'avais fait avec un système à
peu près similaire la prime au feu sur
lequel nous avons augmenté
l'équivalent de la prime pour nos
personnels ensuite la prime relèvera de
l'employeur et donc c'est ce sont les
collectivités locales qui décideront si
elle s'applique à l'ensemble de leurs
fonctionnaires ce cadre-là et laisse 10
seront aussi dans ce régime là et la
décision devrait être prise dans ce
cadre là les discussions se poursuivent
sur ce sujet mais j'ai évoqué ce matin
la rencontre avec le premier ministre et
les collectivités locales ça n'a pas été
un sujet qui a été évoqué et je ne pense
pas qu'il y ait de contestation du côté
de la volonté des collectivités locales
sur ce sujet mais je ne veux pas parler
en leur nom sur les questions de
monsieur buffet sur les frontières
actuellement les frontières sont fermées
elles sont fermées à double niveau c'est
à dire hors schengen avec aujourd'hui un
contrôle extrêmement strictes de toute
entrée en france qui doit être
expressément contrôle est autorisé il
refusait sauf quelques cas qui font
l'objet non pas d'un clientélisme
particules qui font l'objet d'une
autorisation spéciale qui peut exister
mais nous prenons en compte évidemment d
admission qui sont liés à la citoyenneté
européenne qui lie à la résidence en
france ou qui sont liées aux fêtes de
regagner son pays d'origine en passant
par la france sur les trois cas
d'exception sur lesquels on a des
dispositifs par exemple à charles de
gaulle on a même mis en place des
systèmes sous l'autorité du président
des aéroports de paris qui sont fermés
qui permette du coup de passer sur le
territoire national mais sans pour
autant sortir de la zone fermée de
l'aéroport pour éviter que quand on est
des gens qui passent par la france et
qui découvrent resterai en france dans
ce cadre là et donc du coup sur ce sujet
on a une situation côté aérien assez
facile à maîtriser sur les frontières
intérieures qui du coup pour nous sont
hors schengen ce qu'on a mis en place de
façon systématique parce que là il ya
pas eu de coordination européenne
il ya eu des initiatives l'allemagne par
exemple d'abord des landes puis de
l'état fédéral en gros on a appliqué
principe de réciprocité entre ministères
on s'appelait
en disant bon à partir de mardi au quai
on identifie les points frontière on
diminue le nombre de points frontières
on veille à ce qu'il ya une dérogation
de principe pour les travailleurs
transfrontaliers qui s'il présente une
attestation de m'essayer d'une
attestation d'emploi dans pays voisins
puissent circuler
la seule contrainte qui existent
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on a diminué le
nombre de points de passage pour arriver
à avoir dans les deux sens un contrôle
opérationnel qui je crois marche plutôt
bien
donc c'est vrai évidemment sur l'espagne
sur l'italie sur la suisse on est dans
schengen n'est pas dans l'europe sur les
pays-bas sur la belgique sur luxembourg
et sur l'allemagne
donc aujourd'hui on est dans ce qu'est
le royaume uni parce que c'est chez sce
europe schengen le royaume uni sur
lequel on a discuté spécifiques se
posant la question de la suite ça n'est
pas stabilisée au moment présent
le président de la république a évoqué
la fermeture hors schengen avec une
échéance que l'on peut penser
relativement longue mais il ne l'a pas
précisé
il y aura un conseil européen de la
semaine prochaine qui devrait aborder ce
sujet là et au moment où je vous parle
laurent nunez est en train ou a fini en
visio un conseil j'aille des ministres
de l'intérieur que nous tenons toutes
les semaines pour arriver à une
coordination européenne sur ce sujet là
ce que nous n'avons pas réussi à londres
et coordination européenne sa gestion
des frontières intra-européennes nous
espérons que nous arriverons à le gérer
de meilleures façons à la sortie sauf
que nous ne sortons pas tous au même
rythme donc l'exercice n'est pas simple
mais je vous livre notre objectif est
pour le plan national
c'est dans le cadre de la mission des ti
jean castex que nous devrons définir
cela sous une quinzaine de jours pour
faire en sorte que nous inversions la
logique
le président de la république ce qu'il a
présentée dans son allocution de lundi
soir c'est le fait qu'on puisse donner
plus de liberté en des confinant au
français parce que on contraindre à plus
ceux qui sont susceptibles de présenter
un risque et donc tout ressortissant
étranger qui viendrait d'un pays à
risque qui viendra en france il faudra
contrôler des préconiser des solutions
et donc du coup le confinement
obligatoirement différentes formes sont
des hypothèses sur lequel le
gouvernement travaille
sur l'espace schengen d'éloignement
faible je crois avoir répondu et nos
personnels dans les cra oui il ya deux
questions sur les grappes ont des moyens
de protection il y à un sujet lié à la
présence des avocats et la présence des
associations qui très tôt se sont
relativement d engager certaines du jour
au lendemain on décidé qu'elle ne
viendrait plus alors que logiquement une
relation contractuelle que nous avons et
et du coup ont aussi contribué au
recours pour la fermeture des cra mais
ça n'empêche pas le fonctionnement et
l'assistance dont les personnes retenues
en droit de revendiquer
je crois avoir répondu merci monsieur le
ministre nous passons maintenant à
monsieur hervé et à monsieur k nerfs et
tout d'abord monsieur k nerfs s'agissant
des services de la sécurité civile oui
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
effectivement nous nous répartissons la
tâche de contrôler avec le qu'hervé nous
avons en charge la sécurité civile en
particulier le sort des sapeurs pompiers
dans cette période si compliqué vous
avez rappelé à juste titre il ya
quelques instants que les sapeurs
pompiers relever essentiellement en
termes de rapports hiérarchiques et
financier aussi des collectivités
territoriales sauf ceux de marseille et
de paris qui sont placés sous votre
autorité en tant que fonctionnaire
d'état
mais vous avez l'autorité opérationnel
sur les sapeurs-pompiers et donc la
question je voulais vous poser en
premier lieu était de savoir quels
moyens de protection il pouvait espérer
bénéficier dans les opérations
aujourd'hui qui sont d'urgence sanitaire
que nous connaissons vous avez rappelé
votre mobilisation pour les
fonctionnaires de l'état
est ce qu'il y a des contacts
privilégiés avec les départements et
notamment l'assemblée des départements
de france pour vérifier que l'espère
pompiers en activité aujourd'hui son
protégé dans leurs différentes
interventions notamment par les masques
les gels hydro alcooliques ou encore les
gants ils en ont d'habitude mais la
multiplication des interventions peut
amener à une forme de saturation en
termes de moyens puis une deuxième
question vous avez évoqué le ramadan
prévue pour le 23 ou le 24 avril
nous savons qu'il peut y avoir des
provocations vous l'avez vous même
évoqué je vous en remercie des
provocations totalement dommageable la
question que je voulais vous poser c'est
est ce qu'il y a aujourd'hui une
réflexion sur les risques de guet-apens
dans le cadre de ces provocations qui
pourraient bien sûr toucher en
particulier les sapeurs pompiers il est
clair qu'il n'y aura pas de
rassemblement en tout cas aux officiels
mais dans les quartiers prioritaires de
la ville que je connais bien pour avoir
été
ministre de cette politique pendant
trois ans je sais qu'il peut y avoir des
débordements et dans lesquels les
pompiers seraient les premières victimes
potentielles
monsieur hervé bazile me suis par
exemple sud ministre j'aurai donc deux
questions complément de celles que vient
de vous poser patrick kanner la première
sur les questions d'articulation de la
compétence du samu avec la compétence
des pompiers puisque c'est quand même un
sujet important et dans notre territoire
les samu les smur sont amenés à
intervenir et est souvent des pompiers
également y compris notamment sur les
questions d'évacuation sanitaire de
certains centres hospitaliers vers
d'autres centres hospitaliers dans
région moins concernés comment quel
retour vous avez vous sur cette
articulation importante est par ailleurs
vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure la
question de la reconnaissance de la
maladie professionnelle du coffre vide
comme maladie professionnelle vous avez
dit que vous attendiez une réponse à ce
que cette réponse est imminente ou à ce
qu'est ce que il faudra encore attendre
quelques semaines pour avoir cette
réponse et rassurer les pompiers
notamment mais ils sont pas remis et
évidemment d'autres être exposé à ceux à
ce virus est peut-être malheureusement
pour ceux qui sont concernés qui aurait
donc il y aura des séquelles devoir
justifier la reconnaissance de mètres de
là maladie professeur je remercie ses
ministres merci monsieur le président
monsieur le sénateur globalement sur la
mobilisation des sapeurs pompiers au
profit de la gestion de crise et et et
et de l'ensemble des acteurs de la santé
je vais évoquer note que j'ai sous les
yeux en vous disant que quand je les lui
elle m'a impressionné et pourtant je
suis comme vous un élu territorial local
j'étais administrateur d'un se disent et
donc je juge c'est la polyvalence des
sapeurs pompiers professionnels et
volontaires
mais ce que j'ai vu dans la note que je
vais évoquer très rapide mandroux c'est
vraiment cette capacité d'adaptation
parce que ce sont des acteurs
territoriaux avec des connaissances
territoriale personnel des liens etc qui
travaille à la fois sous l'autorité d'un
conseil des ministres à sion d'élus et
en même temps du préfet et ça donne une
culture qui est assez significative et
je peux vous dire que leur engagement
est total personne n'en doute mais en
appui en soutien sur toute une série de
sujets d'abord ils ont assumé une
administration de l'accueil très vite
partout c'était nécessaire dans un très
grand nombre de départements
ils ont plus mis en place des structures
intermédiaires d'accueil de patients les
avis du monde hospitalier avec des
tentes des postes des postes médicaux
avancés des modules d'appui ils ont
répondu là aussi avec une grande
approche pragmatique et l'ont fait vous
avez évoqué le lien avec les smur ils
ont très vite fait un soutien la
couverture opérationnelle des smur
globalement partout mais pas partout
parce qu'il ya des endroits encore dans
ce pays où ça se passe pas bien entre
les blancs et les rouges
je le regrette et si certains savent les
complémentarités en étant chacun à sa
place
d'autres ont plus bloquée il m'est
arrivé d'avoir des hélicoptères même de
la sécurité civile qui ne soient pas
utilisés parce qu'il n'y avait pas de
sapeurs de médecins de l'hôpital
disponibles et qui n'avait que à mettre
de la sécurité civile et je vais pas
donner l'endroit mais c'est arrivé je
m'en suis ouvert parce que je ne
comprends pas comment ce genre de
dysfonctionnement peut faire mais
globalement soutien opérationnel très
puissant au smur partout c'était
nécessaire un appui logistique sous
forme de prêt d'équipement là aussi de
façon très volontariste très engagé très
proches du terrain ce que chacun et
chacune ici connaît bien des moyens
humains mis à la disposition parce que
il ya une évolution il ya eu un
transfert il ya moins d'accidents de la
route
aujourd'hui on sait que c'est un sujet
de forte en gueule de forts engagements
et de fortes mobilisations nos sapeurs
pompiers et donc du coup ils se sont
engagés aussi pour armer d'autres moyens
nécessaires en tant que de besoin ils
ont apporté aussi
renfort significatif sur la régulation
des appels et sur la régulation des
appels du 15 en particulier sur lequel
normalement ils n'interviennent pas je
ne vois pas le débat sur le numéro
unique mais nous pourrions peut être à
présent tirer aussi quelques retours
d'expérience ce serait bien mais ils ont
su aussi se mobiliser sur sur ce sujet
là comme ils ont su aussi le faire en
renfort de mission et si je prends un
dernier exemple qu'on nous en parler aux
gens vont encore plusieurs hier avec les
préfet et les ars c'est l'appui à la
réalisation de tests virologiques en
particulier dans les ehpad
les ars se sont appuyés aussi sur le
réseau des pompiers pour développer les
capacités d'intervention rapide dans les
ehpad pour procéder aux tests
virologiques et donc ou l'armement des
jeux venir ou avec l'armement des
centres qu'ovide et le transfert de
passion donc ils ont répondu vraiment de
façon très significative très engagé et
votre question me permet de souligner ça
ensuite il faut qu'ils aient du matériel
et je réponds à la question du président
caennais il ya une doctrine pour les
équipements individuels de protection et
le dispositif d'accompagnement que nous
avons mise en oeuvre la doctrine
distingue ce que nous avons spécialisée
dans le transfert de malades patients
atteints du coc vide parce qu'ils ont
aussi joué un rôle important dans les
transferts donc avec un niveau de
protection très élevé et ensuite toutes
les autres situations où là encore ont
été mis à leur disposition des moyens
matériels et là encore laissé à
l'appréciation nom revient au débat que
nous avions sur les masques et les
policiers les gelées et pompiers qui ne
sont pas placés sous l'autorité du
messin intérieur font aussi preuve de
discernement et d'adaptation il ya une
doctrine qui a été discuté avec les 10
qui est la doctrine de 50 masques par
semaine et par centre qui permet du coup
d'avoir cet équipement de proximité et
en cas de suspicion de risque
je mets à part les transferts de
patients atteints du coc vide parce
qu'il n'ya pas de suspicion du risque il
puisse faire en sorte depuis d'avoir
toujours ses moyens de protection nous
avons mis en place une fois nous avons
distribué 325 mille masques que nous
avions dans notre dispositif mais comme
vous l'avez dit la règle c'est que ce
sont les 10 qui assurent le matériel
le ballon je n'ai pas eu connaissance
d'incidents d'alimentation
par contre j'ai donné instruction aux
préfets qui était d'être à la
disposition des présidents et des
directeurs de ce discours s'il ya un
trou dans la raquette
on voit comment on aide les pompiers a
trouvé cette solution est donc du coup
sur ce sujet là je pense que les choses
ont été plus tôt plutôt clair il ya un
renforcement des moyens on n'en a pas
parlé jusqu'à présent pour l'outre-mer
est là aussi un engagement particulier
aussi la direction générale de la
sécurité civile et de la gestion de
crise y compris dans les moyens
militaires qui ont été projetés mon ami
aussi des moyens spécifiques de
l'aviation générale de la sécurité
civile gestion de crise pour renforcer
notre capacité d'intervention
mais poser la question de la réponse sur
la reconnaissance ou pas de maladie
professionnelle je n'ai pas il faut dire
que je vais lancer la semaine dernière
donc je n'ai pas au moment présent la
réponse sur sur ce sujet là tout comme
je n'ai pas de vision précises sur le
nombre de personnes dans corps de
sapeurs-pompiers atteint du coc vide
voilà je les boucles de façon évidemment
beaucoup moins précise que ce qu'est le
cas pour la police la gendarmerie ou
pour les personnels de préfecture est
ici une question de ministre cannon qui
parle par expérience la fois
territoriale et ministérielles sur les
risques de guet-apens des pompiers je le
disais tout à l'heure
vis-à-vis de nos forces sécurité
intérieure on n'est pas sur un haut
niveau de tension mais il n'empêche que
très régulièrement on a des agressions
de pompiers et là on a renforcé les
dispositifs la cartographie
territoriales c'est un phénomène nouveau
bond la mise à jour et on la renforce l
été dernier pour faire en sorte que
quand ils vont sur des zones qui console
sont considérés comme potentiellement à
risque qui n'y vont accompagner par des
policiers ou des gendarmes dans
certaines zones périurbaines de
compétences de gendarmes ils n'y vont
que protégé dans ce cadre là après vous
savez comme moi qu'aujourd'hui quand il
ya des guet-apens
généralement c'est on met le feu à une
voiture pour faire venir les pompiers
qui ne sont pas forcément la cible mais
qui sont des dommages collatéraux et
ensuite on attend que la police vienne
et c'est la police qui va être la cible
donc ça c'est un sujet de fond que vous
avez connu en responsabilité que nous
connaissons sur lesquels il nous faut
être très vigilant mais c'est avec les
agressions contre les pompiers qui
viennent sauver les gens c'est toujours
insupportable et ne négligeons pas quand
même que dans plus de 50% des cas
l'agresseur c'est la personne que les
pompiers viennent sauver monsieur le
ministre il nous faut maintenant
reparler des mères les maires de france
élus en 2014 nous rendent à l'immense
service en ce moment malgré le fait que
dans trente mille communes
les résultats du premier tour ont été
concluants ils sont là pour assumer la
permanence de l'action des communes
aussi bien dans des responsabilités de
police administrative nous les avons
évoqué que dans le service aux personnes
et notamment les plus vulnérables
personnes âgées et personnes en grande
difficulté d'insertion bien sûr aggravée
par cette période d'inactivité
mais cette situation ne pourra pas durer
longtemps
vous l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure vous
êtes d'accord sur cette idée mais vous
avez envoyé un calendrier qui me paraît
devoir être réexaminé car le calendrier
qui prévoit un rapport le 23 mai du
conseil scientifique c'est le calendrier
pour organiser le second tour dans les
communes qui ont besoin d'un second tour
ce sont des communes beaucoup moins
nombreuses environ 5000 mais elle
représente de plusieurs millions
d'électeurs et plusieurs milliers de
bureaux de vote
on voit donc que c'est un problème de
grande ampleur compte tenu de la
nécessité d'organiser dans tous ses
bureaux de vente la sécurité sanitaire
des électeurs et de ceux qui tiendront
les bureaux de la question de l'élection
des maires dans les communes qui ont élu
leur équipe
c'est une autre question et c'est une
question qui est complexe elle aussi
bien sûr sinon
l'élection de ces mères auraient pu
avoir lieu dès le 19 le 20 et le 21 mars
et nous savons bien pour en avoir
discuté ensemble longuement la semaine
qui a précédé l'échéance que c'était une
question vraiment redoutable mais nous
avons maintenant un peu de recul le
temps est passé
nous prévoyons le déconfinement pour des
millions de français à partir du 11 mai
et il est plus que temps que le conseil
scientifique nous donne un avis le plus
vite possible c'est d'ailleurs la raison
pour laquelle alain richard et moi même
avons écrit i et au président delfraissy
lui disant il faut absolument que vous
éclairer y est le gouvernement le plus
vite possible sur cette question le
gouvernement et le parlement pour
réfléchir aux conditions qui assurerait
la totale sécurité sanitaire de la
réunion des conseils municipaux et à
défaut reposer la question du vote
électronique que vous avez je crois
récuser après que nous en ayons discuter
et que nous vous ayons dans la loi
mandaté pour prendre des dispositions à
cet égard donc je vais donner la parole
à alain richard qui va vous formulez
précisément les questions que nous nous
posons en tous les cas et je me dois de
vous dire cette attente qui remonte de
tous les maires de france et que vous
avez entendu l'avez vous dit ce matin de
leur association que des dispositions
soient prises très rapidement pour
permettre de mettre fin à cette période
intérimaire
même si cette période intérimaire n'a
pas eu que des inconvénients
parce que au fond les maires qui ont
tenu le manche pendant cette période
étaient des mères expérimentées ils ont
su quoi faire
mais demain c'est l'organisation des
écoles et c'est la reprise
la vie il n'y a pas de raison que les
communes fasse exception en quelque
sorte au déconfinement et qu'on retarde
davantage l'élection des maires monsieur
n'à rien ajouter à ce qu'a dit le
président ce qui est préférable vu
l'état de ma voix je je voudrais
vraiment monsieur muscle on s'assure
bien de comprendre la même chose dans
l'article pertinent de la loi du 23 mars
il y à un décret qui décident l'entrée
en fonction des conseils sur la base
d'indications scientifique et il y a le
rapport présenté au gouvernement avant
le 23 mai sur la question du deuxième
tour donc il y à bien et à ce moment là
ce sera si la décision prise un des
clans conseiller mise puisque l'objet
pas le même donc on a vraiment besoin
d'être sûrs que le gouvernement se
mettra d'accord avec le comité
scientifique éventuellement d'ailleurs
avec d'autres instances qui peuvent être
consultés pour avoir les données sur la
faisabilité de la réunion des conseils
ils ont dans la deuxième quinzaine de
mai en tenant compte en plus des
modifications qui resteraient sur les
conditions de tenue des conseils puisque
on a une règle de quorum ab c'est
d'ailleurs à notre avis beaucoup trop
puisque en révisant la loi adoptée vis
jours avant l' ordonnance a fait rentrer
les porteurs de de pouvoir dans le court
hommes ce qui veut dire que dans un
conseil à cet essai fille d'une personne
pour venir le conseil
donc ça nous pensons que c'est une
erreur du gouvernement d'avoir fait trop
de zèle et je ne pense pas que quiconque
aura envie d'organiser un conseil
d'installation avec moins du quart les
présents ce n'est pas raisonnable mais
en tout cas l'enjeu de la date des
conseils d'installation qui est un
décret après une opinion scientifique et
n'est pas le rapport du 23 mai et
quelque chose pour nous de tout à fait
important je me permet de lisser une
autre question
qui m'est venu à l'esprit pendant la cmp
j'étais le 22 mars map les murs et le
dimanche à propos des outre-mer là où
les circonstances de déconfinement sont
très substantiellement différentes
puisque en réalité
l'élection des conseils à la station les
conseils pour l'action des maires et la
tête du deuxième tour sont des questions
liées à des confinement plus ou moins
d'avancé je me pose la question à
particulier pour les communes de moins
de 1000 pour la majorité d'entre elles
ont 200 300 400 électeurs inscrits
est-ce qu'il n'est pas concevable que
même si le deuxième tour le 21 juin ne
paraît pas réalisable pour les communes
où il y à un grand rassemblement des
lecteurs en revanche là où le nombre
d'électeurs se comptent en quelques
centaines est ce qu'on ne peut pas faire
confiance au maire qui dialogue sur ces
sujets là avec les préfectures depuis la
nuit des temps pour prendre des
conditions d'organisation de deuxième
tour parfois pour deux ou trois sièges
de manière que nous ayons le plus
possible de conseil complet avant les
vacances et que le l'obligation si elle
se vérifie de faire basculer sur un
premier 2e tour à l'automne ou plus tard
j'espère seulement à l'automne ne se
limite qu'à plus grand nombre de grandes
communes aux endroits mais rien ne
paraît l'exclure voilà monsieur le
ministre une percée innovatrices et je
me rallie à cette proposition
immédiatement et sans plus d'examens
même si un examen complémentaire sera
naturellement nécessaire pour l'évaluer
complètement et moi je reformule une
question simple pourquoi ne voulez-vous
pas du vote électronique
mais si on peut assurer partout
l'élection des maires
avec une présence physique des
conseillers municipaux c'est mieux
évidemment
merci monsieur le présent jeu rebondit
sur le dernier point qui sera précisée
pour qu'on les expertises mais qui
serait d'imaginer qu'il ya un second
tour possible en juin dans certaines
catégories de communes puis une
animation et un second tour un autre
moment plus tard d'un point de vue
juridique c'est pas simple quand même
mais du coup il faudra qu'on le
féminicide j'ai pas interpréter
peut-être avec mal écouté mais moi dans
l'axé c'est bien ça monsieur richard
toral encadré par la loi est perturbé
par des considérations de sécurité
sanitaire c'est de façon proportionnée à
ses conseillers considération sécurité
sanitaire qu'on doit rétablir la chaîne
- du process et donc là où le nombre
d'électeurs à réunir est faible moi je
ne vois monsieur le ministre
en plus le droit je m'aventure un peu
mais les 35000 élections municipales
sont indépendantes les unes des autres
ce sont 35 mille élections distinctes
avec d'ailleurs un sujet assez exotique
pour les communes un secteur puisque là
aussi ce sont des élections distinctes
mais donc si les conditions sanitaires
au vu du faible nombre d'électeurs à
réunir des filles au bureau de vote est
limité et que ça permet de réduire le
nombre de communes qui sont mises en
attente avec un nouveau premier tour je
pense qu'il n'y a pas d'obstacle de
droit oui c'est clair quand on ne peut
pas faire le second tour d'ici au 30
juin
il faudra jouer toute la partie premier
second tour indissociables
mais si dans des petites communes on
arrivait à élire les 3 2 ou 1
conseillers municipaux qui nous manque
parce que c'est moins risqué et
d'organiser un scrutin dans un bureau de
vote
où seront convoqués 200 électeurs que
dans des grands bureaux de vote de
grandes villes pourquoi ne pas
l'envisager mais c'est une idée il ya
d'autres questions qui vous sont posées
et donc nous attendons votre réponse est
on peut regarder juridiquement celle-ci
moi je ne pose pas un nom de principes
sur le fait que ce ne serait pas
possible d'imaginer un second tour ait
enfin ou une autre élection parce qu'on
peut y aura des communes de moine huile
ou personne n'a été élu mais si je
prends la dimension sanitaire dans ce
cas-là ça voudrait dire une élection en
juin par exemple techniquement c'est
possible de différencier par strates de
communes la date d'un second tour ou de
l'élection donc on pourquoi pas
l'étudier moi je suis prêt à faire poser
la question et a évoqué cela auprès de
vous même si politiquement ça peut ne
pas être simple et qu'il faudra qu'ils
d'autres personnes que nous ici qu'il
décision mais moi je je je l'entends
avec la dimension sanitaire
ensuite la question c'est un bureau de
vote vous le rappelle en moyenne ces
1000 à 1500 électeurs donc si je prends
le seuil à 1000 dans une commune en
réalité une commune de 3000 qui a trois
bureaux de vote
le risque sanitaire sur le bureau de
vote est le même donc ça pourrait faire
débat mais j'entends j'entends cela et
je pense que juridiquement il ne faut
pas l'exclure
ensuite vous vous posez la question de
l'installation des conseils mois sur le
fond je vous rejoins totalement mais
sans aucun état d'âme d'ailleurs le
texte que le gouvernement avait proposé
prévoyez la remise d'un rapport au 10
mai ne prévoyez pas la remise du rapport
ou d'un rapport c'est important de dire
d'un rapport pour l'installation des
conseils et c'est la discussion
parlementaire qui a enrichi le texte et
qui a posé le fait qu'il fallait un
rapport sanitaire pour décider par des
cribles d'installation des conseils et
quand je dis du rapport ou d'un rapport
c'est pour rebondir sur ce que je crois
être votre analyse nous avons mis
l'échéance du 23 ans vous avez proposé
l'échéance et vous êtes tombés d'accord
avec l'assemblée sur les chances du 23
mai alors que nous avions 2010 mais mais
vous avez liés l'idée aux contrôles
sanitaires mais pas un rapport unique
je reprends le texte qui dit les
conseillers municipaux et communautaires
élue première phrase du premier alinéa
du iii élu dès le premier tour organisé
le 15 mars entre en fonction à une date
fixée par décret au plus tard
juin aussitôt que la situation sanitaire
le permet au regard de l'analyse du
comité des scientifiques et donc vous
n'avez pas lié dans le texte aux
rapports forcément du 23 mai qui de
toute façon et au plus tard le 23 mai et
dans mon propos liminaire j'ai évoqué
ces deux au plus tard c'est celui du au
plus tard le 23 mai et au plus tard fin
juin même si on sait que sur le second
tour ce sera forcément où le 21 ou le 28
juin
compte tenu des délais de convocation et
la remise du rapport au 23
donc moi je suis prêt à enfin je vous
l'indiquais vous avez saisi le
conseiller scientifique
si le conseil scientifique nous donne
son sentiment positif sur la tenue des
conseils et c'est très différent de la
tenue des élections et donc on peut en
autonomie dans les conditions qu'elle
exhibe tenue serait sécurisé au plan
sanitaire et qui nous préconise
effectivement cette dimension là pour ce
qui me concerne je n'ai pas d'opposition
de principe d'ailleurs ça a été évoqué
ce matin sous l'autorité du premier
serait promu se demander de regarder ce
pas aussi donc je n'avais pas en tête
que vous aviez saisi le haut conseil je
suis prêt à les solliciter aussi pour
qu'ils nous produisent dans la mesure de
leurs capacités à n'excluait plus à
l'aise c'est le gouvernement le
sollicite aussi mais c'est certain je
veux dire voilà on a là dessus la même
ambition si l'installation peut se faire
vite
une fois que nous sommes sortis du
déconfinement pourquoi pas avec des
conditions qui sont précisés vous avez
interrogé monsieur le président sur le
vote électronique je n'ai pas récuser
mais je vous ai répondu par courrier
sans récuser mais pour dire qu'à mon
sens les mesures de simplification des
règles procédurales que nous avons
élargi le plus possible et que le
ministère de la cohésion des territoires
a très fortement élargis vous l'avez
évoqué dans votre intervention ne me
permet pas à mon sens par le vote
électronique de garantir le secret qui
est liée à l'article l 21 22 du code
général des collectivités sur la
désignation de personnes
et quand j'interroge les spécialistes je
ne suis pas non plus même si je suis un
tout petit peu meilleures sur ces sujets
là que sur la question médicale
il je ne sais pas comment avoir une
origine non traçable d'un mail qui me
donne le vote d'alain richard conseil
municipal de saint-ouen l'aumône est
d'être sûr que je peux le décor et les
du fait qu'il a proposé le vote de telle
ou telle personne c'est sur cette
question de la sécurité que j'étais mal
à l'aise et donc je ne suis pas sûr
d'avoir raison on vous en vous aurions
répondu mais j'ai le sentiment que nous
ne garantissons pas aujourd'hui avec la
technologie dont on dispose de la sûreté
de l'anonymat du vote et qu'on peut
toujours tracés avec une adresse ip par
exemple et c'est assez facile l'origine
du mail et donc le fait d'identifier
celui qui a voté pour intel c'était ma
seule réserve monsieur le ministre si
c'est votre seule réserve
je crois qu'elle pourra être levée je
comprends que vos propres services ou
assez traumatisés par des expériences
antérieures qui n'ont pas toujours été
des réussites ça a été le cas notamment
en france pour les français de
l'étranger
mais ça n'était pas votre responsabilité
de celles du ministère de l'intérieur
principalement à l'époque nous avons
pris soin d'auditionner un certain
nombre de prestataires de services et
nous en sommes ressortis pour faire
court avec la conviction que le secret
qui est évidemment pour nous aussi une
exigence majeure
il s'agit pas de verser dans une forme
d'amateurisme et de fascination pour les
technologies nouvelles m'enfin les
applications existent depuis longtemps
votre propre ministère s'en sert pour
les élections professionnelles et je
crois qu'il a à coeur d'apporter ou à
ses agents toutes les garanties de
l'anim de l'anonymat du vote vous avez
vous même vos services ont l'expérience
et je crois que il faudrait réellement
consulter directement les prestataires
ce que nous avons fait pour s'assurer
qu'elle est choses sont possibles
d'autant plus que se pose un problème de
compte à rebours
alors nous avons le choix entre deux
possibilités ou bien le conseil
scientifique fait très vite elle vous
donne les indications et vous pouvez
prendre des dispositions pour que le
vote se fasse dans des conditions
proches
de l'habitude ou bien vous considérez
que on ne peut pas faire très vite comme
ça et je crois qu'il faut réinterroger
la possibilité du vote électronique qui
n'est tout de même pas une improvisation
de dernière minute simplement c'est vrai
que faire ça dans des milliers de
communes ça demande une dépense qui
n'est pas négligeable et donc il faut
aussi s'interroger sur le la comparaison
bénéfice coût si nous pouvons organiser
d'ici le début du mois de mai les
élections des maires autrement et c'est
sans doute préférable mais le temps que
nous n'avons pas consacré à la
préparation du vote électronique il est
irrattrapable certaine façon de tout
récent mais d'abord c'est votre opinion
nous allons discuter de nuit à ce moment
là et peut-être qu'une autre option
aurait été de modifier le code électoral
et de considérer que le caractère secret
du vote n'était pas nécessaire c'est pas
le choix que vous avez fait moi je
l'entends bien moi ce que je sais c'est
que je trouverai toujours un prestataire
de service qui me garantira la sécurité
de fonctionnement de mes réseaux
électroniques et je connaîtrai toujours
quelqu'un par expérience qui pourront
vous raconter comment ils étaient
piratés et je fais une différence entre
des votes professionnelle ou deux cent
mille personnes soit amené à voter et le
conseil municipal de saint martin les
sign dans ma circonscription qui compte
14 électeurs qui est la plus petite
commune de 14 habitants plus d'électeurs
qui était la et commune de ma
circonscription qu'il est toujours sur
lesquelles je ne suis pas sûr que je
puisse leur garantir le secret du vote
dans les meilleures conditions et donc
je ne voudrais pas porter atteinte au
caractère du bulletin du vote à scrutin
secret alors inquiet pour les agents du
ministère de l'intérieur à la table ou
du jeu mais je la subis monsieur le
président je pense qu'un vote de deux
cent mille personnes sur par
électronique n'a pas le niveau de
sécurité que j'attendrais de la
désignation par est du vote pour le
maire d'une commune
nous pouvons avoir une différence
d'appréciation sur ce sujet et je pense
que les prestataires seront toujours
prêts à nous dire qu'il n'ya pas de
problème assure la sécurité
je vais juste un qui s'engagent sur un
montant financier important pour me
garantir que son système est
inattaquable inviolable etc
et je pense que j'aurai un peu moins de
personnes qui voient là peut-être que
nos discussions étant ouverte au public
je relis mes féminisé je n'interviendrai
plus sur ce point mais vous êtes prêt à
lever le secret du vote
mais vous n'êtes pas prêt à prendre un
risque qu'un secret soit éventuellement
divulgué parce que le dispositif
informatique ne serait pas suffisant
mais quand même il ya plus de secrets
avec un dispositif informatique sécurisé
qu'en levant le secret je titre
personnel et comme les interroge garde à
la confidentialité du vote à bulletin
secret qui est prévu dans la loi
je pense qu'il ne faut pas transiger
avec nous pouvons considérer qu'on
pourrait prendre un certain niveau de
risque
je pense que ça n'est pas important je
vous réponds là en plus en appréciation
en plus
après l'analyse juridique et technique
qu'ont fait les services du ministère de
l'intérieur
mais ça je comprends que ça puisse faire
débat mais je pense même je vais
jusqu'au bout de ma pensé qu' il vaut
mieux attendre quelques jours et avoir
un maire pour l'avoir été pendant
longtemps et savoir l'importance aussi
du conseil municipal du rassemblement
des femmes et d'hommes dans un conseil
municipal
il vaut mieux avoir un maire qui ne
soient pas élus par mail mais qu'ils
soient légitimes et aussi par
l'installation d'un conseil municipal
le tout dans le respect des populations
sanitaires et s'il nous faut pour cela à
assumer d'attendre de trois semaines
nous pouvons débattre longtemps mais
voilà après vous savez moi j'ai connu il
ne vous a parlé de votre par mail pardon
j'avais dit que je n'en prendrait plus
la parole mais il est intéressant de
vous entendre aussi et sur le lot
rganisation le conseil scientifique et
comment le faire puisque nous n'y fait
seulement on n'ira pas au vote
électronique
comment le faire dans des conditions
sanitaires satisfaisantes le plus vite
possible
d'abord en attendant l'avis du conseil
scientifique ensuite les choses sont
assez simples il est prévu qu'un décret
organise cela sur un délai de
convocation que nous veillerons à faire
raisonnable par rapport à la convocation
d'un conseil municipal que nous
arriverons à faire raisonnable par
rapport à la mise en oeuvre des
contraintes sanitaires que pourrait
préconiser et à ce moment là nous
pourrions aller le plus vite possible
pour cela il n'y a pas d'obstacles du
côté du gouvernement et je vous lis
d'autant plus que nous n'avions pas
prévu
la sollicitation au 23 mai et cette
échéance du 23 mai dans le texte parce
que nous avions anticipé la possibilité
d'un de déconfinement qui se fasse plus
vite encore que celui vers lequel nous
orientons et donc il a toujours été dans
la volonté du gouvernement que cette
installation se fasse le plus vite
possible et je crois même que dans nos
échanges avoir exprimé le fait que ça me
semble pas nécessaire de lier les deux
sur ce contrôle là tout comme l'échéance
du 23 mai n'est pas une échéance que le
gouvernement n'avait avait proposé pour
sa mise en oeuvre donc dès que nous
avons un retour du conseil scientifique
et je prendrai le relais de votre
démarche
parce que nous y sommes favorables s'ils
nous conseille ben non c'est nous
indique que nous pouvons tenir les
élections elle après la sortie du
confinement dans de bonnes conditions
avec une donne des préconisations
accessible à toutes les communes de
france qui ont sonné ce qui est installé
leur conseil municipal nous avons tout
intérêt à le faire
se pose aussi la question même interrogé
dessus mu levac
ce matin je parle là ou non des
collectivités locales jours apportent
leurs propos il ya la question des opci
avec le régime intermédiaire mais on a
aussi beaucoup travaillé sur les
hypothèses pour le faire fonctionner au
mieux on connaît la fragilité aussi et
les ep s'ils sont nécessaires et les
grands opci songeait alors le plus gros
investisseur le plus gros acteur aussi
des solidarités territoriales je ferme
la parenthèse sur ce sujet mais je vous
rejoins totalement et je prendrai le
relais auprès du conseil scientifique
via le ministre de la santé pour qu'ils
puissent nous éclairer le plus vite
possible sur ce sujet là et donc je
rejoins votre ambition et je crois avoir
répondu aux questions sur ce dossier
merci monsieur le ministre nous avons
dix collègues qui suivent assidûment nos
échanges et qui demande la parole je
vais leur demander de se restreindre
et de poser des questions qui ne
prennent pas plus d'une minute je vous
demande de m'excuser je regrette
beaucoup de questions déjà été posée le
ministre a répondu
dans les détails avec beaucoup de bonne
volonté et de clarté et donc je vais
vous donner la parole dans l'ordre que
je vais énoncer pour que vous vous
teniez près monsieur bonhomme monsieur
du rhin monsieur waterblez monsieur le
comte monsieur reichardt monsieur
mohamed soly monsieur marc monsieur
fille chez madame jourda madame di folco
donc monsieur bonhomme
vous avez la parole
en panne d vous monsieur le président je
vous entends
vous pouvez vous pouvez poser votre
question mr questions sur la j'ai eu des
informations selon lesquelles le
commissariat de cannes par exemple la
sauce elle qui compte 250 effectifs
avaient 35 cas de positif qu'ovide donc
plus de la moitié n'ont pas été
contestées j'aimerais savoir qu'est ce
que le ministre compte c'est pour
essayer d'enrayer cette propagation de
même sur une compagnie crs
originaire de l'aude dans l'occitanie
qui d'entre eux n'est actuellement
ajaccio sur 70 hommes 10 cas serait
positif est évidemment eagle hill 2 cela
nécessiterait d'être testée dans leur
retour pour éviter le aussi eu un risque
un risque urgente était en fait j'avais
une question concernant la cohérence des
pratiques monsieur vous n'avez parlé
dans votre propos liminaire les
concernant l'ouverture des marchés le
décret du 23 mars dernier fixe des
conditions aux éventuels de tenue des
marchés alimentaires couverts ou non et
celui ci renvoie à trois conditions pour
autoriser l'ouverture de ses marchés
pour peu que ces trois conditions soient
respectées
je m'aperçois que selon les départements
les précédents ne nomme pas fait
maintenant pas fait la même
interprétation et notamment dans mon
département ou trois communes de
tailleur plutôt modeste et surtout dans
le département à vocation de son mari
calme et rurales pourraient sans doute
monsieur est obligée de demander de
conclure et malheureusement à ce jour
elles n'ont pas obtenu de dérogation
alors même que dans les départements
voisins et je pense que je dis donc
d'exemple monsieur bonhomme
entendez-vous de ville voulait zinou
route et où des dérogations
préfectorales
dans mon département je constate que ça
n'a pas toujours été le cas
alors même que nous emmenons merci chers
collègues le ministre a bien noté votre
question merci les cohérences et
l'interprétation de ce décret pour
l'autorisation par derrida cieux où il
est le plat ministre a bien compris le
sens de votre question chers collègues
je vous en remercie et je passe
maintenant à monsieur du rhin monsieur
durand
je vous recommande de ne pas utiliser
votre caméra parce que ça occupe trop
d'espacé dans la bande passante et on
vous entendant ça on vous entendra mieux
sans caméra et je vous ai parlé ça
monsieur le président et je me posais
une question le ministre sur les
doctrines qui ont été passés au corps
préfectoral en matière de sortie du
confinement
le préfet de mon département la
saône-et-loire délicatesse de relayer
sur les réseaux sociaux à une
publication d'un député émérite de la
majorité qui appelle les gens à
retrousser leurs manches à se remettre
au travail
député qui est par ailleurs candidat aux
municipales en dehors de cette question
est liée au devoir de neutralité
2 je voulais comprendre comprendre
quelle était la doctrine qui avait été
passé au préfet je crois que c'est un
mixte subtil entre l'accélérateur de la
reprise maîtrisé et le frein du
confinement sanitaire ce sujet il est
partout dans l'actualité on le voit avec
amazon dans le secteur privé on voit les
questions que ça pose en matière de
fonctionnement diam's postale on le voit
aussi dans une collectivité avec la
question de la réouverture des
déchetteries par exemple donc est ce que
le corps préfectoral jean clair en
matière de sortie du confinement matière
économique
merci monsieur merci de votre concision
chers collègues je donne la parole à
monsieur watts blé
l'entreprise entendait très bien bon ben
j'ai trop de questions mais je vais
faire très vite aujourd'hui plus
ministre
pensez vous que le disputera sa volonté
et centre parti pas bleu toulouse aura
un effet positif sur la sortie du
confinement d'aplemont n'a pas un
smartphone et il ya des gens qui savent
pas s'en servir
aurons-nous un nombre suffisant et c'est
peut-être pas de votre soeur mais le
test de dépistage pour répondre à la
demande de tests en sortie de banc en
ciment et un troisième comme le cas de
la corée il ya une brigade humaine en
corée qui suit qui sont de vingt mille
personnes ont suivi 56 mais en habitant
est en france il en faut mais
concrètement 30000 pour nos santés 11
millions d'habitants
alors ma réponse je serai peut-être ne
faudrait-il pas rendre le port du masque
obligatoire lors de la sortie du
confinement dur merci merci beaucoup
chers collègues je donne maintenant la
parole à monsieur le comte pour une
minute monsieur le comte
ah voilà vous m'entendez monsieur vous
avez une minute chers collègues le
ministre de questions monsieur le
ministre est ce que vous pouvez nous
faire un point sur la situation de
l'enregistrement de la demande d'asile
dans préfecture est-ce que c'est
totalement arrêté aujourd'hui est-ce que
ça se fait un petit peu comment on se
sortira du confinement en faisant en
sorte que personne n'est capable de
droit est-ce que vous pouvez nous faire
un point sur ce sujet
deuxième question les ordonnances
relatives à la vo prolongement de drogue
toujours ont été prises pour les visas
pour les pour les titres qui étaient
exclusivement de la compétence française
toutefois il ya visas de court séjour
schengen pour des personnes qui ont pu
se trouver bloqué ce territoire français
et qui ne peuvent pas partir pour
l'instant compte tenu de l'arrêt des
lignes aériennes
qu'est ce qui est prévu pour ces
personnes qui aujourd'hui ont d'elisa ou
des durées de d'autorisation de séjour
lorsqu'ils sont ressortissants d'un pays
sans le segment d'une obligation de visa
qu'est ce qui est prévu pour ces
personnes pour pouvoir reconnaître
finalement le fait qu'ils ne peuvent pas
retourner dans le pays
j'ai posé une fois la question au
ministère des affaires étrangères mr
européenne on m'a dit qu'il fallait
qu'il rentre alors en préfecture pour
proposer une prolongation de séjour
territoire mans limité mais ça me semble
un peu compliqué et ce qu'il n'y aurait
pas une démarche à faire au niveau
européen pour que les personnes qui sont
dans ce type de situation puis de
manière générale merci beaucoup et même
plongement merci chers collègues merci
beaucoup je donne la parole à monsieur
reichardt
monsieur reichardt vous n'avez pas
ouvert votre micro monsieur reichardt
vous avez la parole mais pour cela il
faut que vous actionnez votre micro vous
oui chers collègues allez-y mais ce
président ce ministre mes chers
collègues
bonjour bon je vous avais deux questions
j'avais plus question de points
particuliers le premier concerne
l'incompréhension de beaucoup de nos
concitoyens l'égard de la grande
diversité que qu'il constate dans les
niveaux différents contrôles des mesures
de confinement
je voudrais illustrer sa pourquoi dans
le département qui lui a le bar à deux
personnes formant un même couple ne
peuvent pas sortir ensemble dans le
cadre de naturellement des dispositions
dérogatoires au confinement
alors que par ailleurs il voit sur les
réseaux sociaux que sur certaines lignes
de transports collectifs en île de
france et wagons sont aussi remplies
qu'auparavant ce sont les contrôleurs
qu'ils disent ce ministre vous avez dit
vous même qu'il ne fallait pas avoir
peur des joggeurs alors que on voit à la
télé des groupes des défilés de joggeurs
qui naturellement ne respectent pas les
règles de distanciation sociale monsieur
ministre ma question est ce qu'il est
possible de deux de nos concitoyens de
voir une plus grande cohérence dans la
mise en oeuvre des mesures de
restriction du confinement et puis un
deuxième point très rapide vous avez mis
l'accent sur l'importance de la mission
des élus locaux
naturellement tour normal dans la crise
que nous traversons même non membres en
effet ils ont reçu une instruction leur
notifiant que le rôle de police
administrative spéciale mise en oeuvre
dans le cadre de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire passait bien au dessus des
mesures de police générale
je dois vous dire très franchement que
certains n'ont pas tout compris ils ont
le sentiment que
ils ont ils mériteraient une confiance
accrue dans ce dans ce dossier je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues merci beaucoup
monsieur thani mohamed soly pour une
minute
chers collègues vous avez la parole
allez-y monsieur mohamed soly
allez-y monsieur thani mohamed soly vous
avez la parole oui très bien
vous avez la parole monsieur mohamed
soly
apparemment vous ne m'entendez pas
peut-être pourriez-vous bonjour cela
très bien monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues j'ai trois questions précises
quelle est la mobilisation des forces de
l'ordre de deux forces de sécurité
intérieure à nous trouver
face à cette crise je demanderai d'état
ces forces de sécurité d'autant plus que
malheureusement la délinquance de droit
commun n'a pas là pas cessé deuxième
question
qu'est-il prévu pour les demandes
d'évacuation sanitaire vers les
territoires d'outre-mer de vote
ressortissants nationaux se trouvant
dans des pays voisins de ces territoires
alors qu'il nous faut préserver nos
capacités médicales d'un territoire et
une troisième question un cas à gérer de
couronnes à virus en provenance des
communes de des comores a été recensé 1
mayotte
du coup il ya un risque réel de reprise
des trafics des grattoirs un des comores
à destination à destination de mayotte
hier le préfet a annoncé un certain
nombre de mesures supplémentaires et
notamment
le concours de l'armée pour faire face à
cette situation
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire plus
la population et il est évidemment
inquiète et a craint légitimement vague
supplémentaire de contamination qui
pourraient provenir la centrale merci
beaucoup de collègues
merci beaucoup de votre de vos questions
merci je donne la parole maintenant
monsieur alain marc bonjour monsieur le
président vous m'entendez très bien vous
m'entendez bon ma première question bien
sûr concerne les marchés de plein air il
semblerait que la doctrine de monsieur
le ministre est un petit peu changé
puisque au départ lorsque par exemple
dans un village il y avait une supérette
les marchés de plein air était interdite
or aujourd'hui les drive ne suffise pas
à empêcher un petit peu la catastrophe
économique qui concerne donc nos
producteurs et il semblerait quand même
que les maires parfaitement responsable
s'achète organisait des marchés de plein
air qui sont la sécurité sanitaire et
parfois meilleure que celle qui est dans
les magasins donc je souhaite que vous
réaffirmiez monsieur le ministre
supprime soviétique au début deux autres
propos liminaire ensuite pour ce qui
concerne l'installation des conseils
municipaux
certes il faut attendre le 23 mais moi
je pense qu'il faut le verrou quittant
le 23 mai ce que vous avez dit le
sixième du conseil scientifique
en effet on ne comprendrait pas qu'on ne
puisse se réunir ont les plus grosses
fils de l'aveyron par exemple 35
conseillers municipaux dans des salles
équipées de 2000 m² et ne pas respecter
les consignes sanitaires
il me semble que c'est me paie à bas et
je ne pense pas qu'il faille être grand
mais 200 savoir si on va colporter le
gobie 19 dans des conditions qui
seraient complètement assurée enfin vous
savez les maires des retraites
les pourquoi je disais cela c'est parce
que les budgets de ne pas été votée et
que vous avez par exemple que au niveau
des travaux publics
80% de la commande vient des
collectivités locales or si on veut
assurer une continuité et une reprise
économique
il faut bien en passer par le vote par
des tout images ici ensuite merci
beaucoup le cher collègue attendait
juste une allez-y mais très brièvement
les aides d'état notamment la detr
d'autres aident beaucoup de maires
craignent que à l'issue de cette crise
économique sans précédent ces deux ci
soit revue à la baisse nous aimerions
avoir des propos rassurants de monsieur
le ministre
merci merci beaucoup chers collègues
merci je donne la parole à monsieur
fisher vous m'entendez la très bien cher
collègue monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues
alors monsieur le ministre les festivals
de cet été sont dans une prison majorité
reporter ou tout simplement annulée
c'est hélas y ont engendré d'énormes
difficultés financières pour ce même
festival et se pose même pas la question
de la survie il joue un grand rôle bien
évidemment bâtir culturelles artistiques
mais aussi économique dans nos
territoires
avez vous une attention monsieur
ministre de revenir sur l'application de
la circulaire colons qui imputent les
coups de sécurité d'assistance
extérieure à la charge des budgets de
ces mêmes festivals pour la sécurité
incendie et secours aux personnes et une
possible d'imaginer a été département de
surseoir sur d'annuler totalement ses
champs de services publics qui sont
aussi qui incombe aussi au festival
deuxième question monsieur le ministre
réitère ce matin matin a indiqué que les
petits festivals pourrait se tenir après
le 11 mai alors comme il s'agit pour
recharger de contrôler la tenue de ces
festivals
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire quelle
est la jauge qui permet de déterminer à
partir de quel moment il s'agit d'un
petit festival
je vous remercie
merci beaucoup chers collègues je donne
la parole à madame jourdain
quand je vous remercie messinis vous est
merdique et tout à l'heure qu'il fallait
agir vite et fort
jean sommes tous d'accord n'y at il pas
néanmoins une contradiction sur le
terrain avec le fait que nous avons au
moins quatre interlocuteurs des services
de l'état le préfet la rs l'éducation
nationale le diable dans les finances
publiques dans une moindre mesure
ne faudrait-il pas nommer un chef de
fille qui serait le préfet et dans le
cadre du déconfite mans qui va être trop
le sel pression extrêmement délicate
ne faudrait-il pas non seulement que
nous ayons un chef de file mais qu'il
est plus haut à ces places pour les
adapter et travaillé notamment avec les
collectivités territoriales que les
aigles ou coup je voulais un assez grand
rôle sur le terrain je vends merci merci
beaucoup cher collègue madame di folco
mais bonjour monsieur le ministre de
questions
la première concerne les mariages les
mariages seront ils autorisés de nouveau
à partir du 11 mai nous avons là faut
que les restaurants les bars ont
confirmé jusqu'à la mi-juillet les orcs
estivale et rassemblements et c'est
aussi donc un mariage est-il considéré
comme un grand rassemblement est
deuxième question il semblerait que les
résultats consolidés du premier tour des
élections donc 15 mars n'aura pas
affichés sur le site du ministère de
l'intérieur
comme cela se fait traditionnellement y
at il une raison à cela
si on remercie merci beaucoup chers
collègues de ces questions et enfin
dernière question de madame mercier
si toutefois madame mercier est toujours
présente nous entend et bien tant pis
tant pis je suis désolé pour madame
mercier monsieur le ministre vous avez
la parole merci monsieur le président je
vais tenter de pao oublier un certain
une question sur le ministre il n'y en a
que 25
il ya certains sénateurs qui ont une
minute pourtant posé 5 bon monsieur
bonhomme sa situation de cannes je ne
sais pas la situation particulière de
cannes ce que je peux vous indiquer
c'est qu'au sein de la police nationale
il ya un moment où je vous parle
identifié 309 personnes sur un volume de
150 mille agents qui sont reconnus au
titre du coc vide 19 comme malade et il
y a huit 1369 isolé sanitaire parce que
puisque nous pratiquons c'est le
confinement relations massif dès qu'on a
un cas avéré de que vides
c'est une doctrine qui n'est pas
appliquée partout de la même façon et on
a voulu le faire de façon assez
significative
c'est pas simple nous est arrivé de
neutraliser une compagnie de crs ou un
escadron en entier mais parce que nous
ne voulons pas prendre de risque par
rapport à la situation de de nos agents
il ya la question de les tester de faire
les tests de façon systématique je
voudrais vous rappeler que aujourd'hui
notre objectif est d'avoir cinquante
mille tests par semaine qu'ils soient
disponibles
c'est le rôle des préfets et des ars de
faire monter en puissance tous les
laboratoires les plus larges possibles
je signale d'ailleurs que le laboratoire
de police technique et scientifique de
la gendarmerie de la police aujourd'hui
mobilisée et réalise des tests
c'est une adaptabilité que je voulais
souligner mais tous les laboratoires de
ville et cetera sont en train d'être
agréée par les préfets pour pouvoir
élargir est monté en puissance fortement
sur ce sujet la priorité les publics
prioritaires identifiés aujourd'hui sont
un public dans les ehpad dans les
hôpitaux le personnel de santé mais il
nous faut évidemment monter en puissance
sur ce sujet est ce que je veux dire
c'est que et pour être encore confrontés
à des cas récents que je connais bien
vous d'abord on a un taux de 2
d'appréciation d'efficacité à 60 70 %
seulement sur ces tests et en plus dans
les premiers jours ou pour être testés
négatifs alors que vous apporterez du
cohabitent donc de toutes façons le test
est un bon indicateur mais ne permet pas
de régler toutes les situations mais je
veux insister sur ce sujet les préfets
les rs s'emploie vraiment identifier les
capacités existantes c'est un des sujets
sur lequel j'ai mis la pression sur les
préfets
hier soir avec le ministre de la santé
sur lequel nous devons agir et comme je
m'adresse au sénat je sais aussi votre
approche territoriale important ce cas
là on a des départements qui sont en
fragilité parce que le laboratoire ne
permettent pas de et d'objets
expressément demandé au préfet de région
d'organiser une solidarité
infrarégionales pour que nous fassions
en sorte qu'un département qui n'a pas
la capacité de répondre à toutes les
sollicitations en ehpad par exemple et
on sait qu'on peut avoir au niveau des
pad dans la ruralité et pas forcément un
haut niveau de capacité de laboratoires
nous puissions répondre présent sur sûr
je reprends les questions monsieur
bonhomme jeudi sur la montée en capacité
sur les marchés vous êtes plusieurs à me
reposer la question
on est dans un vrai paradoxe c'est que
d'un côté il ya une interdiction totale
des marchés et nous avons fait confiance
à l'intelligence territoriale des
préfets sur la base des préconisations
des maires pour nous faire des
propositions pour qu'il y ait des
arrêtés de dérogation à l'ouverture des
marchés
nous avons élaboré une doctrine une
documentation il ya une fiche technique
qui étaient à la disposition de tous les
maires et qui permet du coup de voir si
le maire dit moi je sais organiser le
marché sans qu'il y ait un risque
sanitaire qui soit posé ensuite le
préfet vérifie cela est valide cela mais
effectueront dès lors que je fais la
confiance à l'intelligence territoriale
d'applications j'ai pas une doctrine
forcément unique commune la doctrine
commune c'est l'interdiction
ça c'est assez facile il n'y a pas de
différence dès lors qu'on est pour une
approche territoriale et où je laisse la
responsabilité aux préfets d'apprécier
la situation et de décider au cas par
cas
je peux avoir une différence d'un
département à l'autre et c'est tout le
paradoxe dans lequel nous sommes tous
quels que soient nos opinions politiques
c'est que on aime bien la dimension
confiance territoriale expérimentation
mais le corollaire de sas est comparé à
des appréciations qui sont différentes
d'un territoire à l'autre
mais ce que je veux dire à monsieur
bonhomme comme à la marque c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il ya des arrêtés
dérogatoires qui augmente fortement
je n'ai pas changé de doctrine je peux
vous dire qu'après l'intervention du
premier ministre le soir même j'étais en
visio avec les préfet j'ai rappelé le
cadre l'interdiction mais la possibilité
de déroger sous certaines conditions et
avec une méthodologie particulière et je
n'ai cessé de le rappeler le 30 mars il
y avait 2000 257 marché qui avait été
autorisé par arrêté à ouvrir le 6 avril
3373 le 13 avril 3629 et donc s'il ya
des sollicitations c'est dans ce cadre
là qu'elles doivent être traités
monsieur le sénateur du rhin a évoqué
une doctrine de déconfinement qu'un
député aurait diffusé et m'interroger
savoir quelle était la doctrine de
déconfinement que nous avions donné aux
préfets il n'y en a aucune
les choses sont claires le présent la
république a passé une commande celle de
présenter la doctrine de déconfinement
sous 15 jours
et donc il s'agit pas de cacher quoi que
ce soit mais se serait imaginé que nous
soyons extrêmement productif et surtout
jean castex qui anime cette réflexion là
de façon interministériel la doctrine de
déconfinement sera présenté globalement
dans quinze jours elle sera à les
préparer nous y travaillons et donc j
ignore ce qu'est ce de ce document mais
ça n'est en aucun cas une doctrine de
déconfinement c'est une analyse peut
être un document je ne sais pas mais je
suis prêt à a précisé la la réalité de
ce document mais ça n'est en aucun cas
une doctrine de déconfinement monsieur
le sénateur wattebled m'a interrogé sur
le traçage d'abord vous vous re préciser
que c'est pas un dossier qui relève du
ministère de l'intérieur mais je peux
dire ce que cédric au secrétaire d'état
en charge de ce sujet là auprès du
ministre de la santé la société a
rappelé que le président la république a
repris le scénario central sur lequel
aujourd'hui certaines personnes
travaillent c'est un téléchargement
volontaire et avec un seul objectif
celui de la prévention et la maîtrise
des risques de contamination je le dis
très clairement mais c'était pas le sens
de la question du sénateur wattebled
mais comme je sais qu'il ya quelques
inquiétudes sur ce sujet le ministère de
l'intérieur n'est pas concerné par les
opérations de tracy
tracking c'est un dispositif qui ne
relèvent pas de nos attributions qui
aurait pas de mission du ministère de
l'intérieur et qui du coup dès lors qu'
on est sur quelque chose qui serait un
téléchargement volontaire n'a pas
vocation à être demain contrôlé sur ce
sujet notre compétence à nous ce sera
d'exécuter ce qui sera décidé par
d'autres en fonction des opportunités je
veux préciser que sur ce sujet vous
aurez l'occasion de vous exprimer le
président la république a souhaité qu'
anne débat sur cette application
je l'appelle entre guillemets
application volontaire et facultatives
qui aura lieu devant l'assemblée devant
le sénat ça me paraît absolument
importante on touche à des choses qui
sont extrêmement sensibles mais sur
lequel je voudrais réaffirmer que nous
ne sommes pas directement concernés
c'est un terme aux tablettes mais
interrogé aussi sur les tests de
dépistage sur le nombre suffisant quelle
est la limite du nombre suffisant si
nous testons tous les gens qui veulent
vérifier qu'ils n'ont pas le coc vide
c'est 65 millions de personnes par jour
qu'il faudrait tester
parce qu'en plus on peut être porteurs
asymptomatiques donc c'est cela aucun
pays au monde n'est en capacité n'a mis
en place ce dispositif là et donc nous
montons fortement en puissance sur les
différents types de dépistage veux pas
me prononcer parce que je ce n'est pas
mon secteur ministériel
mais aujourd'hui c'est là où nous en
sommes de la même façon le sénateur
m'interroger sur le fait de rendre le
port du masque obligatoire cela relèvera
d'une décision sur la base de données
sanitaires et scientifiques que ça ne
relève pas du ministère de l'intérieur
monsieur je vérifie si j'ai bien répondu
oui monsieur le comte
vous m'interrogez d'abord sur les
demandeurs d'asile je vais vous préciser
les chiffres de mars
nous avons enregistré trente mille 30 et
une entrée dans le dna alors que nous
sommes sur une moyenne mensuelle si je
prends la référence l'année 2010 9,2
6297 seulement il ya eu 15 jours sans
fermeture de frontières et donc c'est
pas très représentatif non plus faut
avoir en tête qu'aujourd'hui il ya très
peu d'entrer dans notre pays il ya des
entrées quand même il ya très peu
d'entrées parce qu'il ya un contrôle
assez significatif à l'entrée de
l'europe
je prends par exemple la porte marocaine
de phénomènes migratoires il ya une des
contrôles ensuite à chacune de nos
frontières donc ça a fortement baissé et
en particulier depuis le 18 mars mais je
n'ai pas d'indication sur 18
fin mars plus précise que cela je
voudrais vous redire le sénateur qu'il
est possible de déposer une demande
d'asile soit par les procédures à la
frontière et soit pour les publics
vulnérables accompagné signalés
notamment par les associations sur le
territoire national vont fermer les
guichets de gestion de l'accueil mais
nous avons maintenu des agents qui
travaillent sur ces sujets là et qui
peuvent parfaitement intervenir
m'interrogeais aussi sur les visas court
séjour qui serait dépassé nous avons
prévu un dispositif simple de
prorogation et il n'ya pas normalement
de problèmes pour avoir un rendez vous
qui se fait par téléphone avec les
préfectures ou de tous les services
normalement sont censés être même si
soit un effectif réduit disponible pour
répondre à des questions précises qui
sont donnés donc nous avons prévu la
provocation et j'évoque un sujet ça
n'était pas le sens de votre question
mais on a par exemple le cas des
saisonniers qui viennent tous les ans en
france mais qui n'ont un visa que valve
ap six mois qui sont actuellement en
france et qu'ils peuvent pas repartir et
qui ont une activité agricole en
perspective
nous avons prévu la dans lordonnance qui
est passé en conseil des ministres où
qui va qui est passée là nous avons
prévu par ordonnance je vais être plus
prudent la possibilité d'une prorogation
de trois mois pour constater qu'ils ne
peuvent pas rentrer chez eux qu'ils sont
en capacité de travailler sur le
territoire national géré shirt vous
m'avez parlé d' incompréhension à de
grandes diversités j'ai tout à l'air
évoqué le fait qu' évidemment 150 160
mille personnes le week-end dernier qui
font des contrôles
l'appréciation d'une situation qui est
différente d'un territoire à l'autre
mais surtout au quotidien de la
rencontre avec la situation et passe par
le prisme de 160 mille personnes qui ont
reçu une unique instruction mais dans
l'exemple que m'est donnée je suis très
étonné parce que je vous le dis deux
personnes peuvent si elle remplit leur
attestation essais prévus dans le cadre
d'une sortie familiale sortir ensemble
et donc je suis très surpris qu'il peut
y avoir un contrôle
j'ai eu le cadre d'un contrôle il y
avait une seule attestation rédigé pour
les deux effectivement ce n'est pas
prévu nous demandons qu'il y ait deux
attestations qu'ils soient remplies et
puis monsieur le sénateur richert
semblait me faire reproche d'avoir dit
elle que je ne fallait pas avoir peur
des joggeurs non je n'ai pas peur des
joggeurs parce que je pense que
le confinement total et absolu qui n'a
été mise en place dans aucun pays
j'ai pas de référence pour la corée du
nord mais qui n'a dit mise en place dans
aucun pays se heurte à des besoins
physiologiques
je pense qu'à certains moments il faut
accepter c'est pour ça que nous l'avons
prévu que l'on puisse sortir une heure
par jour qu'on puisse sortir et
s'éloigner à un kilomètre de son
domicile et donc du coup y compris pour
des gens qui courent voilà ce que je
voulais dire j'ai senti que mon propos a
été mal interprétés je ne pratique pas
le jogging sauf sur un tapis de course
et donc de ce côté là j'ai pas de
difficulté d'attestation pour la
confiance accrue entre les communes les
préfets je crois vraiment l'avoir dit et
et pour avoir rencontré ce matin toutes
les associations d'élus aucune n'a mis
en avant de crise de confiance contre
les communes et leurs préfets il ya des
endroits où c'est plus compliqué que
d'autres
c'est lié à la nature des relations
humaines mais le message que je passe de
façon permanente c'est celui de la
discussion
et je n'ai pas déferré notamment sur les
arrêtés qui imposait le port du masque
de façon obligatoire
j'ai dit nous ne décevrons pas mais nous
allons échanger avec le maire pour
préciser pourquoi nous considérons que
ce n'est pas juridiquement valable le
conseil d'état se prononcera dans les
heures qui viennent d'ailleurs sur ce
sujet et pourquoi au fond ça peut être
un mauvais message envoyé nous le voyons
bien d'ailleurs un aujourd'hui dans le
relâchement sur le confinement par des
gens qui considèrent que parce qu'ils
ont un masque ou un foulard
ils peuvent sortir et s'alléger des
contraintes des gestes-barrières et du
confinement
ça n'est pas le cas et c'était le sens
de mon propos mais nous ne faisons pas
de procédures contre les maires il ya pu
y avoir quelques engueulades de trois
endroits j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure et
généralement elles se sont fortement
pacifiée dans la foulée le sénateur
thani mohamed slim a interrogé sur
globalement la mobilisation des forces
et je les ai répondu tout à l'heure nous
restons totalement mobilisé sur
l'ensemble du spectre du droit commun
mais par exemple je sais pas si tu es
cet exemple petit judiciaire aujourd'hui
n'est pas une priorité d'instruction du
ministère de la justice par entre ce qui
relève du haut du spectre entre
guillemets oui et donc évidemment nous
sommes mobilisés sur le haut doubs
être sur le respect des échéances par
rapport aux procédures je sais que la
garde des sceaux a mis en place aussi
une vigilance particulière sur ce sujet
avec ses services et donc nous répondons
présents pour ne pas négliger cette
dimension là ensuite vous allez poser la
question monsieur le sénateur
particulière que vous connaissez
sûrement sur mayotte où effectivement il
ya la situation migratoires que nous
connaissons sur lesquels nous sommes
montés en puissance avec la mobilisation
démobilisés de moyens particuliers dans
le cadre de l'opération chic andra mais
c'est vrai que pour l'instant mayotte
n'est pas trop touché par le cos vite 19
mai nous connaissons la situation
sanitaire sociale très délicate de
mayotte c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous aurons pris avec la mise et
d'outre-mer toute une série de
dispositifs pour vous protéger
mayotte mais aussi les outre-mers
contenu de situations particulières que
nous pouvons connaître
nous avons au moment où je vous parle
trois navires qui sont h24 autour de
mayotte mobilisés pour lutter contre le
risque d' immigration clandestine doublé
du fait qu'il peut y avoir un risque lié
aux colis de jeudi qu'il peut y avoir un
risque parce que je crois que le
gouvernement comorien indique l'absence
de cas aux comores je sais que la
population n'y crois pas et je n'entends
par prendre pour argent comptant ce qui
nous est précise et parce que de toute
façon une fois un dispositif de
surveillance particulier je sais que
depuis le 6 avril
on a lui quoi ça à quinsac qui ont été
identifiés comme arrivé à proximité ou
sur terre deux ont été repoussés six ont
été interceptés à leur arrivée mais
c'est vrai qu'on a une tension dans la
relation avec les comores pour les
reconduites ensuite alors qu'on en
discute yves qui en temps normal est
beaucoup plus fluide et beaucoup plus
efficaces que ceux que nous connaissons
ce que je veux dire aux sénateurs c'est
que nous allons poursuivre notre
mobilisation des moyens de l'opération
chic andra et que nous ne baisserons pas
la garde sur ces questions là et puis on
va poser la question plus globalement
des transports des évacuations
sanitaires à destination de l'outre-mer
ces dispositifs evasan qui fait l'objet
d'une approche spécifique
on a plusieurs de nos postes
diplomatiques qui ont saisi les
autorités de demande d'évacuation
sanitaire vers les territoires
d'outre-mer de ressortissants nationaux
européens
on prend cela en compte tout en
préservant en prenant en compte la
capacité médicale des territoires
d'outre-mer et on sait déjà qu'il nous
faut et d'ailleurs on a prévu la mise en
place d'un de moyens aériens de type
evasan entre mayotte et la réunion c'est
effectivement pour prendre en compte les
capacités relativement faibles que nous
connaissons en matière de soins et pour
faire face à un risque élevé de cuves
vides sur l'île de mayotte est donc
évidemment chaque cas sur laquelle nous
sommes sollicités et fait l'objet d'une
évaluation particulière mais nous
prenons en compte ses demandes
d'évacuation sanitaire vers les
territoires d'outre-mer pour nos
ressortissants nationaux et européens à
charge pour nous ensuite s'ils sont
européens de veiller avec leur pays
d'origine est ce que le passage en outre
mer comme le passage sur le territoire
national globalement ne soit qu'un hub
pour un retour ensuite vers vers son
pays je poursuis des questions à la
marque a évoqué les marchés donc je vois
là la doctrine n'a pas changé je l'a
réaffirmé gelard et affirmerait encore
si besoin sur sur ce sujet là c'est un
sujet dont géré par l'eia avec le
premier ministre et je peux vous dire
que notre intention c'est pas d'empêcher
les marchés mais c'est de faire en sorte
qu'ils puissent se tenir dans les
conditions sanitaires et des ailes je
n'ai pas d'inquiétude ou de craintes
parce que je n'ai pas d'information sur
la detr qui ne relève pas de mon
ministère et sur l'installation des
conseils municipaux c'était dans la
première partie de notre discussion avec
même le souhait dans la mesure du
possible de pouvoir anticipées sur
l'échéance du 23 mai parce qu'un marque
était sur le le texte et la discussion
préalable que nous avions ce fichier
m'interroger sur les festivals et les
petits festivals
le ministre a ce matin fait des annonces
nous n'avons pas travaillé ensuite sur
la mise en oeuvre de cela nous allons
faire dans les jours qui viennent
il me paraît nécessaire que les règles
et les indications les plus précises
soit donné aux organisateurs le plus
vite possible ce que je sais c'est qu'il
ya une cellule spéciale au cabinet du
ministre de la culture qui répond à
toutes les sollicitations en termes de
conseil et évidemment la css mettra à
disposition du ministère de la culture
pour que nous puissions définir ensemble
ce que sont les petits festivals les
règles sanitaires qui devront
être respectées et nous appartiendra
nous forces de sécurité intérieure de
les mettre en oeuvre
madame jourda a évoqué la difficulté
d'avoir plusieurs interlocuteurs je sais
j'étais maire suffisamment longtemps
pour le savoir ce que je conseille mais
ça n'est pas la loi que je vous donne
mais ce que je conseille c'est que les
élus n'hésitent pas à solliciter les
préfets de tous les sujets sur lequel
ils sont mobilisés et il appartiendra au
préfet de faire le lien si besoin avec
la rs ou avec une autre autorité
donc je suis prêt a réaffirmé cette
dimension là à l'amdi folio m'a posé des
questions qui relèvent au fond de la
stratégie de déconfinement et donc qui
seront précisées dans le cas de la
doctrine globale sous une quinzaine de
jours et donc pour l'instant je n'ai pas
d'éléments je n'ai pas d'éléments de
réponse précise à ce sujet je pense que
les résultats des élections municipales
sont disponibles sur le site du
ministère mais sur la référence
data.gouv.fr sur lequel résultats sont
disponibles je pense que c'est le cas
parce que si vous prenez n'importe quel
moteur de recherche en fait ils ont fait
algorithme qui viennent chercher sur
data.gov la formation et donc je pense
qu'on doit pouvoir trouver cela et
madame merci elle n'était pas avec nous
et donc je ne vais pas de questions à
répondre à monsieur le ministre
pour ce qui nous concerne dans cette
audition vous êtes pratiquement au bout
de vos peines
mais mais précisément puisque vous avez
la courtoisie de rappeler que madame
merci et ruth et vous poser une question
je vais la pause et en son nom et j'en
profiterai aussi pour vous poser la
question que vous aurez posé madame
traîné pour madame mercier je crois que
la question d'ailleurs été abordés au
cours de notre audition elle rappelle
que le gouvernement a décidé que le
dépistage du coc vide 19 serait mis en
oeuvre prioritairement pour les
personnels soignants et pour les
personnes âgées des ehpad et les
personnels des ehpad
elles demandent est ce que les policiers
les gendarmes ce sera le cas aussi et
madame tremblay qui est également très
fort que vous connaissez au service de
la suite de la protection civile et des
sapeurs pompiers demandent si des
enfants des sapeurs pompiers sont bien
accueilli par tout comme les enfants des
soignants voilà les deux ultimes
questions
j'applique sur le dépistage pour ce qui
concerne les agents du ministère de
l'intérieur les doctrines qui sont
déterminés par ministère de la santé la
solidarité donc je rappelle que la
priorité est accordée compte tenu de
notre capacité je donne le chiffre tout
à l'heure aux personnels de santé et aux
ehpad et ensuite sur préconisation des
médecins ils ont la capacité à
solliciter and control pas il n'y a pas
de contrôle systématique du dépistage
pour les forces de sécurité intérieure
sur l'accueil des enfants de pompiers
c'est aussi une priorité qui a été donné
à l'ensemble des personnels à l'ensemble
des enfants des personnels de santé
puis nous avons demandé aux préfets de
faire un point précis département par
département des capacités d'accueil
supplémentaires qui seraient disponibles
avec évidemment consommer enseignants
qui sont mobilisés ils n'ont pas
souhaité dire ok on fait une classe un
peu différente mais pour quarante
enfants
donc c'est effectivement sur des effets
nombre qui permettent de sécuriser la
santé des enfants accueillis et la santé
des enseignants aussi mais donc c'est
sur la base de ses capacités que nous
avons élargi et nous avons évidemment
élargi aux personnels des pompiers à la
fois pendant leur intervention mais même
plus globalement partout il y avait de
la place
globalement ça marche bien mais il peut
y avoir des départements nous n'avons
pas été en capacité d'accueillir
l'ensemble des enfants soient des forces
de police y est essentiellement parce
que les gendarmes vivre en caserne on
est sur des problématiques différentes
soit des pompiers plus globalement je
pense que le dispositif a plutôt bien
marché de ce côté là
bien monsieur le ministre je vous
remercie au nom de tous les collègues
présents est relié par visioconférence
vous avez eu à coeur de répondre très
précisément à nos questions en y
consacrant tout le temps nécessaire
malgré une charge que nous devinons très
lourde et je tenais à vous en remercier
bien vivement la séance est donc levé
voilà pour cette audition de christophe
castaner ministre de l'intérieur devant
la commission des lois du sénat
une audition sur la crise du cornet
virus et notamment sur le respect du
confinement des français pendant cette
crise sanitaire
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi continuer à vous informer
sur cette crise sanitaire sur notre site
internet publicsenat.fr
je vous souhaite une très bonne soirée
sur public sénat
[Musique]
m
non